e
e e
yeah I'll
I'll good morning today is Thursday
January 23rd 2025 this is the the New
Hampshire House of Representatives
Municipal and County government
committee I am representative Diane
power the committee has convened today
for the purpose of public hearings as
well as an executive session this
afternoon now please make sure that your
cell phones are silenced and please join
me in reciting the Pledge of Allegiance
led by representative Guthrie
Al to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
with liberty and justice for
all thank you at this time the clerk
will take
attendance good morning
chairman power present present Vice
chairman McDonald
present representative
Guthrie representative Dolan
here representative
Elward did I say that correctly
okay the clerk is
present representative France
here representative
krinsky
here representative Murphy
present representative Walker
present representative stavis present
representative Gilman
here representative magor
here representative
frock
no representative Colby here
representative gerana
here representative Gerard
here representative grundt
here thank
you so before we begin our business
schedule for today I have a few morning
announcements so as I said the committee
has convened today at 9:30 for public
hearings on seven bills after the public
hearing scheduled at 11:20 a.m. or
around that time the committee will
break for lunch then public hearings
will resume
at
1:00 and following that at approximately
1:40 or thereafter the committee will
hold executive sessions for the 7 bills
that we heard last
week so additionally I have the
committee contact list
here please verify your information if
you've provided it and if you have not
um please fill that in and initial after
your name if you would like your
information to be shared with the
committee
only and once that's finalized I will
distribute hard copies to to the
committee pass that
around next in order for the committee
to stay on schedule today the chair will
allow for up to five minutes for Bill
introductions by Prime sponsors or there
or a design and then that will be
followed by a question and answer
period also the chair will allow up to
three minutes for public testimony with
additional time allowed per speaker for
Q&A if the speaker
allows if a speaker has written
testimony I would ask that you would
please provide a hard copy to
representative kazinski so that it can
be shared and distribut uted to
committee members for their
consideration um as a reminder to
speakers providing in-person testimony
here today when you um are called and
you take the seat there I would ask that
you please remember to state your name
who you represent in your position on
the bill support oppose or neutral
for the record before you start um
speaking so once you start speaking and
that's that's you you've done that and
then you start speaking today we we will
need to keep time and once your 3
minutes is up the vice chair will signal
and then we can go into Q&A for further
to obtain further information on the
bill that you're speaking
to so when the clerk is ready you ready
um we'll
begin so at this time I will open the
public hearing on House Bill 139
relative to the official designation of
holidays by municipalities and
educational
institutions so I would like to welcome
representative
Horgan to introduce this bill to the
committee
thank you very much I'm represented
Timothy Horgan from um straford County
District 10 which is the town of Durham
and um I uh I'm pleased to be here I
didn't think I was going to be able to
make today and so I I thank
representative both representative
howand and Howard and Howland who are um
also um were ready to ready to step in
so I thank them for for coming over and
they're like uh they're both like after
me in the alphabetical order on the
roster of uh State reps but anyway so
written testimony I handed it out and
it's uh basically it's pretty simple
currently municipalities and school
districts are at least in theory
forbidden to celebrate any special day
Which con conflicts with official
holidays so this law you know in my
opinion is an overreach which violates
the principle of local control and I
actually like Drew up a uh list of them
and how they're how they're designated
New Year's Day Martin Luther um and I
also although ironically in the list I
rather hurriedly so I forgot to leave
out the for Columbus Day I forgot to
leave out the part about how it's
determined that's probably the most
controversial one that's the second
Monday in October but just about all
those days uh all those days conflict
with some other uh some some some other
other observant
so communi should be free to observe
whatever holidays they please and
there's nothing wrong with celebrating
multiple occasions on the same day and
sometimes renaming a holiday is okay too
so I know um I think I think what
prompted is is uh several communities
including mine um prefer to observe
indigenous people's day on um the second
Monday in October and that's uh that's
no disrespect to any any any other
ethnic group Columbus was a
controversial historical figure but uh
he has become his the day of his voyage
is a uh associate both with Italian
Americans and then not so much in the
English speaking world not so much
outside and outside America the Spanish
speaking world it's all it's since he
was really more Spanish and Italian it's
a it's a holiday most of those countries
like it's often called Elia de laasa you
know the day of the the day of the
Spanish speaking peoples but that's um
anyway so I probably already went beyond
my written written testimony by be happy
to take any questions
so thank you representative other
questions for the prime
sponsor seeing none thank you thank you
so yes it's just a you know just a
simple uh support of local control
so next the chair calls Mr Mike
dagel welcome to Municipal and County
Government
it's red is oh now you can hear me when
we start again okay hi um my name is
Mike dagel I'm a resident of of
Portsmith New Hampshire I'm here
speaking on behalf of myself and uh I am
in opposition of uh HB
139 um in early
2024 the New Hampshire legislature
passed and Governor sonunu signed the
extremely bipartisan House Bill
1014 this bill contained two significant
sections the first section required
school public schools in their civic
classes to teach about election laws and
voting the second section seeks to make
the naming of holidays uniform
throughout the state in all cities towns
municipalities and public
schools it
requires um not in theory that any
municipality or school that has a
holiday following or falling on a date
specified in state law uh which is RS
say
288.15
one holidays the same throughout the
state of New
Hampshire now I'm not a legal scholar
but I also believe
that this follows the Dillan law form of
government that New Hampshire
has traditional holidays carry deep
cultural historical and emotional
significance that connects generations
of people and fosters a sense of shared
Unity preserving these holidays is vital
to naming the cultural heritage to
excuse me to maintaining the cultural
heritage and communal values uh they
embody changing or modernizing in
traditional holidays creates confusion
with no real benefit to
anyone hb14 memorializes our state's
proud tradition of recognizing cultural
heritage noteworthy events and
historical figures maintaining
traditional holiday names throughout the
state throughout all local and state
agencies ensures that future Generations
understand and appreciate the origins of
these celebrations
HB 1014 does not require a municipality
or school to declare a holiday on the
dates in RSA 288.15
that have a local holiday on one of the
RSA 2881 named holidays must call it
specifically what the state requires
nothing more nothing less for example a
school cannot dequire the third Monday
in January other anything other than
Martin Luther King Day excuse me Martin
Luther King Jr Civil Rights Day a town
could also have a holiday on December
25th and call a Christmas day but cannot
change the holiday's name from Christmas
day to Saul en victus day as require as
decreed by the satanic temple Mr dagel
am I too long yes oh I'm sorry your your
time has expired okay um we we are
interested in what you have there so if
you have anything um printed we we can
could I email it to someone because I
only brought one copy and I have notes
all over yes yes thank you thank you
very
much um would you willing to take
questions questions for Mr
dagel seeing none I oh oh I'm sorry you
were leaning back rep uh the chair
recognizes representative Dolan for a
question thank you and thank you for
taking my question uh my question is uh
more focused on the
education impact of these holidays I
know you talked about the different uh
uh holidays but as it affects those in
school uh and the fact that U missing
school is a can be accumulative serious
impact is there anything in this
language or this law that that uh is
being proposed that would make up so for
example if you had took
indigenous people's day as a holiday is
there anything that says well if the
municipality or the school board picks
that as a holiday that they have to have
a makeup educational day the next week
or the next month or whatever do you
know anything in there I I do not know
anything representative um I think
actually that the way the current law is
structured um by mandating what scho
schools and municipalities call holidays
um teaches them proper Civics this is a
Dylan rural state if I recall um it
teaches them also and um uh to um um to
be able to understand how um uh history
Etc if the municipalities wish to have a
separate day you mentioned indigenous
peoples days as an example nothing in
this law stops them from doing
it the the as I understand the current
law it does it just requires them if
they're going to have um a a a holiday
on Monday in October whenever it is
it'll be called Columbus Day I think
it's the second Monday maybe your third
Monday in October um but they can call
indigenous people's they I believe the
United Nations has calls has a um um a a
holiday entitled um indigenous people's
day which is different than Columbus Day
if that answers your question
sir additional questions
seeing none thank you Mr dagel thank
you the chair calls representative
Howland welcome back to Municipal and
County government representative thank
you um I'm Al Holland I represent
straford 20 which is Durham Lee Madbury
and a sliver of do do Ward 4 um and I'm
speaking in favor of the bill um I was
on the durm Town Council in 2017 when we
changed Columbus Day to indigenous
people's day and I was also on the
oyster for school board in 2018 when we
followed suit um that came after a
couple of years of
community questioning a painting that
that is in our uh our local uh post
office and it really speaks to the
Oyster River raid which occurred in 1690
when the French uh working with the
abanaki attacked the Garrison on the
Oyster River it resulted in 104 deaths
and 21 captives it is probably one of
the most significant uh historical
events in Durham and really significant
in terms of New Hampshire in US history
and we really felt that uh while you
know Columbus really did have and and
all of the uh the ex the uh the
explorers that came from Europe really
had an impact that this really to our
community was significant and so we we
decided to change it uh to indigenous
people day I support this because what
happened was uh a couple of years ago
there was legislation that came that
really tried to force all municipalities
to do indigenous people day this took
the 180 which is to try to force all
municipal ities to do Columbus Day we
really wanted to restore local control
there has been no evidence that any of
the other dates have been changed by any
municipality it's only a minority that
occurred that was uh indigenous people
day this would restore their right it
would not take away any other
municipalities uh right to do Columbus
Day that would really be up to them and
it's up to their voters and I can tell
you it is a long and painful process to
change the a uh one of these dates and
so
we're just asking you to allow us to go
back to what we did before we just think
that this we don't think that the state
should mandate it we think it should be
local control and I think that came
under two
minutes thank you representative Holland
questions repes the chair recognizes
representative mat majori thank you
madam chairwoman and thank you
representative and welcome back I I was
hoping you would speak because maybe you
can uh I think you might have some
familiarity with my question uh I've
negotiated many of the collective
bargaining agreements in my community
and one of the components of most
collective bargaining agreements is
major holidays do you think this bill in
any way would have an effect on the
major holiday uh piece of a collective
bargaining agreement if those collective
bargaining agreements might extend uh
might be expansive well actually it
already did because um the collective
bargaining agreements that were
multi-year agreements that that were in
place in 2024 if we had negotiated them
before uh the new bill last year took
place the language in our collective
bargaining agreement said indigenous
people day uh and so when the state
changed it it it really threw off our
our already negotiated agreements I
think that's fairly easily amended
either way as I say I I think um I think
one of the questions was why don't you
add another day and it's exactly because
of that these are kind of mandated
holidays in both schools and
municipalities we didn't want to add a
day because it add cost we just wanted
to use the day more
effectively further
questions seeing none thank you
representative next the chair calls
representative Susan pelli
good morning thank you for your time
today thank you chair of power I am
representative Susan pelli Rockingham
District 19 Hampton Falls and Kensington
I oppose hb1
139 this bill seeks to remove the common
sense requirement that educational
institutions and municipalities use a
holidays legal title in Communications
Publications and documents our New
Hampshire legal holidays the names are
clearly defined in chapter 288 RSA 288
colon 1 why is this provision to use our
legal holiday name so important because
we must remember to honor our current
holidays holidays reflect our shared
history why do we celebrate or
commemorate holidays these special days
are designed to remember our shared
experiences these special days have a
significant place in history and schools
and mun or municipalities may be closed
to reflect this
importance the current law just passed
last term is very simple it simply s
states that schools and municipalities
use the legal name for state holidays
unofficial Communications like calendars
and documents for example we don't want
Memorial Day to be renamed
arbitrarily and we don't want Christmas
day to be randomly named for example
winter solstice day this would cause
significant
confusion we have a wellestablished
process to add or change legal holidays
and names and I welcome and encourage
everyone to go through the process that
we're going through today let's honor
our current legal holiday names by UniFi
by unifying and sharing our holiday
traditions by respecting the current
legal holiday names used by schools or
municipalities I respectfully request an
expedient to legislate for this bill and
thank you again for your
time that was perfect timing
representative thank you questions for
the
representative the chair recognizes
representative Colby for a
question thank you madam chair um is
there anywhere in this bill or the
current law um as it sits that allows
for a municipality to use two names in
conjunction there's no
there is no Pro U prohibition on that
okay so someone uh if the municipality's
communication went out I'm sorry I had a
followup the communication from the
municipality went out um I'll allow the
followup thank
you that uh you know the office was
going to be closed for Columbus Day
slash indigenous people's day as long as
the legal holiday is represented I'm
sure that the municipality if they have
room on their calendar or you know
whatever other publication can uh put an
additional verbage in
there thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you
representative thank you now also if you
have um written testimony could you pass
that to representative
kazinski thank you
that is the last pink card that I have
on this bill is there anyone present who
wishes to provide testimony who has not
yet had the opportunity to do
so blue sheet
representative representative Kosinski
do we have the blue sheet for this
bill it's it's on the table over there
yeah
okay so if you want to save a trip just
feel free to pass it along the
table read that out just say we have two
people posed in and support just the
numbers for House Bill 139 we have two
individuals that are opposed and one
individual that's uh in support
of on the blue sheet
thank
you at this time the chair will is
closing the hearing on oh yes yes sorry
along with the blue sheet I'd like to
recognize the remote
signin that's possible for this bill uh
there were three uh signed in in support
and 61 opposed but I will note unusually
that 24 of those opposed if work from
out of
state thank you representative
Gilman at this time I will close the
public hearing on House Bill
139 e
at this time the chair will open the
public hearing on House Bill 346
relative to lure fees for racetracks the
chair calls the prime sponsor
representative V
and um after the bill introduction we
have Mr Jake Roger to also provide
public testimony welcome to Municipal
and County government thank you madam
chair good morning to the committee nice
to be here before Municipal and County
government for the record I'm
representative Michael Vose I represent
Rockingham District 5 the town of
eping and it is my pleasure to introduce
to you this morning House Bill 346 FN a
very simple
Bill all it does is
increase the fee that municipalities can
assess on
racetracks in order to license those
facilities that's all the bill does
makes no other changes to
statute why do we allow towns to license
racetracks they're just business
businesses after all like a pet store or
a bakery we don't force those people to
get a
license well we license racetracks
because there is a public safety public
health and safety component to the
operation of a
racetrack we want to make sure that
people who attend races are protected
and kept safe in the process so the
legisl passed Back in 1970 a bill to
allow municipalities to license
racetracks they set in statute at that
time a fee of
$100 up to
$100 uh for the lenser of a racetrack in
today's dollars that $100 would be
$710 95
cents just adjusting for inflation and
nothing else
so why did i s pick $500 as the the new
value for allowing the license licensure
of a
racetrack I chose that number because
I'm pretty conservative when it comes to
spending other per people's money it may
not be be the right number but I trust
that the members of this committee will
figure out exactly what the right number
is if they deem it's worthy of
increasing the fee at all and My Town
Administrator Mr Jake Roger will explain
shortly why the two of us believe that
raising this fee is is
necessary so with no further Ado I'd
like to have Mr Roger explain just what
goes in to creating and a license for a
racetrack by the way eping has two
racetracks the New England Dragway and
the Star
Speedway and I can assure you that
particularly when the New England
Dragway has a national event the impact
on the town of eping
is
epic the traffic flows uh the number of
people who come to eeping for one of
those events is huge
so I'm going to turn it over now to Mr
Roger to explain to you how we go about
making sure that those two racetracks
are safe for the general
public thank thank you representative V
uh as stated my name is Jake Roger Town
Administrator here uh or down in eping
so I'm here to represent our govering
body the select board um and they
support this
bill uh I would do a quick correction uh
which I I won't fault you but we have
three tracks in town now we have a new
one it's MX 101 motocross track so
that's another thing that kind of
triggered this is okay now we're talking
a lot of work that we put in for for all
three of them to inspect and
everything um so I I made a quick
spreadsheet I'm happy to share either by
email or have some copies mailed of each
staff member and then their involvement
and how many hours I broke it down down
to how many hours they spend on issuing
one license to One
Racetrack so we have our town planner
who inspects the track for violations of
our zoning ordinance we have our fire
prevention officer which is the most
significant it's about 6 hours per track
uh she performs inspection prior to
opening day inspects all the satellite
concession locations Hospitality tents
trailers uh our fire chief discusses the
emergency action plan with the tracks
and forms a memorandum of understanding
in with each separate
track our executive secretary prepares
documents for the select board meeting
issues the actual license posts all the
public hearings in information on the
town website and at the Town Hall things
like that our health inspector inspects
all the stands Food Services things like
that and then answers calls or
complaints our police chief reviews and
signs the
application uh and kind of plans out the
details cuz often they need police
details and then I review their proposed
schedules confer with track officials
and explain the schedule to the board
before they approve it each
year so um so I added up the the total
cost including benefits so I took their
hourly rate including benefits because
that's the true cost to the town and all
that came out to about
$698 that it costs us to issue one
license
so if we're charging $100 it's around
$598 that really our taxpayers are
footing the bill for that difference so
now that we're up to three tracks you
know it begins to add up more than
$1,500 that really are our taxpayers are
paying for us to spend all that time
with each
track so that's really what it comes
down to uh we're re we're making a lot
of changes to our racetrack bylaws I end
up digging in into them a lot because we
have three in town and that's why I
noticed that uh that the rate in this
statute seemed low and brought it
forward and I think that's all like I
said I'm happy to share this with anyone
who's
interested thank you I'm not a racing
fan myself so that's why I didn't know
about the third racetrack I don't follow
that real closely
but uh so that's our presentation and
we're happy to take any questions uh
from the
committee thank you are there
questions representative
Gerard thank you madam chair uh the
question I had was in regards I know
you're stating you have several hours
that you're tied up in are there other
types of businesses that have
entertainment value in your community
that you
also have this type of situation
with not particularly the first thing
that comes to mind is our large assembly
permit
which also has a fee which I can't
remember off the top of my head but that
goes through a similar process it's
usually a lot quicker just police fire
public works if they're closing a road
but it's a similar process but
definitely not as many
hours yeah so for example uh on
Halloween we shut down Main Street or a
block of Main Street and have a hallowen
party that the entire town comes to it's
a it's a fairly big significant event
and um that's the kind of assembly that
would require uh a
license followup followup what what type
of fee do you charge for those
assemblies because again it sounds like
you have safety concerns with those
types of events as well right that's why
I was saying I don't I believe it's $100
but I can't promise you that I could get
you that
information thank you Mr Roger would you
be able to um obtain that that
information and and email it to the
committee or have representative o
provide that to us yes thank you further
questions representative Gilman thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question and I will tell you that uh
in exiter if the wind's blowing right I
do hear the New England Dragway um my
question is the difference between the
town uh celebration of Halloween where
he shut down uh Main Street and a
private entity of the
Dragway um do you see that there should
be a difference between the charging the
two well they're obviously different
events but they both have public health
and safety concerns and the purpose of a
license is to make sure that those
concerns are
addressed and I would just say some of
the um Dragway events are you know 5 to
10 ,000 people so it's a lot more
significant
event further questions representative
frock thank you madam chair for taking
my question uh and thank you for being
here before the committee my question is
year overy year how often do some of
these plans
change plans meaning um uh like your
emergency plan your fire
plan um need for police details are
there variations or big changes that are
made I wouldn't say big changes and
that's why so the the fire chief dealing
with that he got he said he takes about
one hour per track that wasn't a a big
part of it is those emergency plans but
drive over to the track meet with the
officials maybe one line and change a
couple items in the document but no
nothing significant and drive back okay
followup yes um in terms of inspecting
your food stands uh the health inspector
does this and my question is do the
people who run the food stands require
any sort of License
to um to vend at these events and if so
what is the cost for that license I'd
have to research that information I
believe they obtain a permit from the
state but I'd have to research the cost
to
that additional questions representative
majori thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you gentlemen uh for being here
and for testifying get ready for golf um
uh my question is statement and question
that the longer I've been here the the
the more I get concerned about having to
revisit bill bills that have a hard
number I understand why we have to have
a hard number is there any reason why
the number or or the language couldn't
be actual costs rather than a hard
number because we're just going to have
to come back and revisit 500 again or a
not to exceed number could the language
say actual cost to the community or
something of the like in your
opinion that's a good question and I
would trust the committee's Judgment as
to the proper way to set into statute
what the fee should be I would guard
against however letting it
be up to the committee to the community
or the municipality to decide that
because we could end up with widely
varying charges you know Lee could
charge $10,000 for a license while eing
charges maybe 1,000 or whatever the the
number number might be so I would I
wouldn't just let the communi set that
number but certainly it doesn't have to
be a hard number in statute it could be
um adjusted by the annual CPI the rate
of inflation or something like that
thank
you further
questions I have a question my question
is is it true that a
municipality publishes the fee schedule
for for these sorts of things so that
it's publicly known and understood what
the fees for different licenses or
permits are I can't think of a statute
or anything that requires us to do that
but we do post all of our ordinances on
our website and our ordinance States the
the
fee any other questions seeing none
thank thank you thank you madam
chair the chair calls Mr Ben
bzowski did I get that name right yes
good welcome to Municipal and County
Government thank you um my name is Ben
bzowski I am the owner and operator of
Hudson Speedway Lee USA Speedway in
clont Motorsports Park um when I heard
about this uh bill being proposed I was
kind of shocked I was wondering
why why you wanted to raise it so high
where our expenses for these racetracks
are growing exponentially every year uh
between um you know food costs uh you
know the bill for the police department
fire department to show up ambulance and
all this other stuff um and I was just I
was just kind of wondering
why it hasn't changed since
1970 uh we do all of our you know for
the inspections we keep everything up to
code we make sure I actually you go a
little above and beyond um just because
like I said Public Safety for me is
number one um I I like I said I'm I'm
not very good public speaking so I'm
sorry if I'm trembling or whatever um
but I I just we're already restricted as
it is we can only run I'll use Hudson as
example I can only run Sundays and
holidays for five hours and I can only
do that for 15 days so when everyone
else can work 365 days a year and can
work eight hours to pay their bills and
support their family and stuff I only
have five hours every Sunday and that's
not pertaining if weather hits or um you
know sometimes I I don't have staff
sometimes so sometimes I'm short staffed
on a lot of stuff so sometimes I have to
cancel the show um and I'll use Lee as
example so uh lee Le beway is my is the
biggest track that I have um they
require me to have six firefighters with
a fir
truck uh roughly
I I believe it's four
officers and an ambulance system there
and that's only for eight hours and I
run 14 times a year on that so I know
500 doesn't seem like a lot to people
but for people like me you know timesing
it by five is a lot for you know just a
small track owner so like I said I just
I was just very shocked on this and
that's really all I have to say
thank you other questions representative
stavis thank you madam chair and thank
you for testifying thank you for taking
my question and you're a very good
public speaker by the way thank you um
you you stated in your testimony that
all of your costs have increased M as
you in your many years in this
business do you understand that the
towns at costs have increase as well I I
agree but the problem is I'm restricted
to time that I the town only allows me
to run to pay that back so you know it
you know if you want to up at 500 but
let me run more times to offset the cost
of that then i' I'd be fine with that
but the town only allows me to I'll use
Hudson as an example I'm only allowed to
run Sundays for five hours and
holidays and I and you know I can only
run on you know I can't run every
holiday I want to spend time with my
family too but that's that's other than
that but it just we're restricted to so
much we're only restricted to narrow
window to pay for our bills so it just I
don't know it just doesn't seem right to
me the chair recognizes representative
frock for a question thank you madam
chair um do you charge admission to your
racetracks yes we do followup please yes
and has your admission price been
constant since I'm going to say
[Music]
1972 uh I don't know what they charged
back in the day but I'm pretty sure
Hudson has always been 15 bucks to get
into the uh the
gate thank
you further
questions I have a oh I'm sorry
representative Gerard
thank you madam chair Mr Bowski I know
you um are talking about three different
facilities other than what eping has
what kind
of how often does the local fire
department police department come for
inspections at the other three year
three facilities uh they come once a
year in the
beginning followup yes about how much
time do you feel they are there with you
at that time um each track's a little
different
uh Hudson is maybe an hour if that uh
Lee's a little more probably
two uh in Claremont I'd have to get my
general manager because he's the one
there there because I'm two hours away
but I'm pretty sure I I can't see that
being any more than an hour and a half
for that for Claremont thank
you additional
questions representative Gerard asked
the question that I was going to ask so
thank
you okay um seeing no further questions
thank you for providing your testimony
Mr bzowski thank you have a good day you
too the chair now recognizes Mr Ronald
jro welcome to Municipal and County
government hello thank you madam for for
giving us the opportunity to speak thank
you for the representatives to attend
the meeting the hearing today um I don't
know what went on prior to this because
through some research I was doing over
the winter I've encountered this bill
and proposal and I do have some
questions for the people that um the the
representative that wrote the Bill but I
wasn't able to ask questions at that
time but um Ben all his answers I think
were correct in a lot of those regard my
facility oh let me introduce myself I'm
sorry my name is Ronald guu I live in
Connecticut I own R&B Motorsports
which owns the property in Wentworth New
Hampshire that currently holds a
racetrack and our representative is here
and I thank her for being here but um
all those things in the way the
representative started off as Billy
didn't want to change nothing but the
amount which is fine but he's looking at
in his from what I understood it's eping
the town of eping has three
racetracks one of them holds a national
event at the Dragway New England Dragway
holds One National event his expenses
for that town maybe a little more
because it's one National event yes they
do race weekly at New England Dragway or
a schedule for the
summer but it's one National event that
is probably a majority of the traffic
and the same with the town of Lowden
with their Nascar event they have one
Nascar event they hold other events
there throughout the year but they hold
one event which really impedes the
traffic in the town but on
that all the towns businesses um hotels
gas stations convenience stores
everything they all benefit from the
people coming to these events in a small
town even the small town gas stations
convenience stores most people I mean at
our facility we have people that come
from all New England states plus New
York Canada Pennsylvania as far as
Georgia to come up to New Hampshire to
race um the licensing fees in my opinion
should be regulated by the town that
makes the racetrack owner or promoter
general manager however you want to word
it work with the town hand inand so
there is no friction between the town
yes racing is noisy we deal with
neighbors that
have concerns on the noise as she said
that the um representative stated if the
wind's blowing correctly she can hear it
yes that happens every racetrack across
the United States of America but these
are small businesses there used to be
RAC tracks at every Fairgrounds around
the country even in New Hampshire I
think there's probably in my opinion 10
to 15
facilities but when you look at other
facilities that have to have inspections
there's a lot of horse farms they hold
horse shows those should all be
regulated I don't know if they're not
it's not my business but Fire Marshals
all them they should because they all
have the same we're our insurance
companies do more of an
inspection to just cover our liability
on a piece of property for what we use
it
for um Mr jro um you've exceeded the
three minutes I knew I was G I was going
to ask you to wave The Checkered Flag
when it happened but I'm just I think
that the O the uh public hearing should
continue because there needs to be more
discussion on this and also for them to
get more information to the public thank
you sir if you have any written
testimony I don't I could submit
something but no I are just notes you
have you would have to do that here
today okay thank you I do not apprciate
your your testimony uh will are you
willing to take questions oh yeah for I
got all
day um the chair recognizes
representative
stavis thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um judging
from your testimony would you then be
comfortable with my colleague's
suggestion
of amending this Statewide law this is
not a community by Community Law it's
Statewide to the actual costs and not a
hard and fast
number uh no I would think it should be
a hard number like it has been since
1970 additional
questions seeing none thank you so I
wish I could go on but thank you
okay so that's the last pink card that I
have is there anyone present who wishes
to provide testimony who has not yet had
the opportunity do to do
so we're waiting for the blue sheet
yep to support
one thank you
U Madam chair chair the uh registration
for opinions REM uh remotely for blue
sheet today uh there is one in favor and
one against and on the remote signin
there are two in favor and one
against thank you representative Gilman
with that I will close the hearing
on House Bill 346
we are doing well with our schedule
next we have House Bill 165 I'm going to
open the public hearing on that
bill and I would like to welcome
representative Aaron the prime sponsor
of the bill to introduce it to the
committee thank you so much Madam chair
and members of the
committee excuse me my name is
representative Judy Aaron and I
represent the town of aworth Goan langon
lster and Washington in Sullivan County
District
4 I'm introducing this bill HB 165 to
you today
relative to the maximum amount of
disaster relief funding provided to
municipalities after a natural
disaster I'm here to correct a wrong
that was made last year when the
language of this RSA was included in a
bill as B 499 that went to a committee
of conference the original Bill language
sought for up to $100,000 to possibly be
awarded to a municipality after a
natural disaster hits their
Community the Senate was adamant that
the governor would not sign the bill
unless the amount was lowered to
$25,000 so it was agreed upon that we
would settle for a severe reduction in
this kind of Grant in order to get the
language signed into
law I'm simply asking with this bill
that the original $100,000 Grant amount
be reestablished because we all know
$25,000 is hardly disaster relief to any
Community it barely helps at all to fix
roads temporarily or to be used to help
get a community running again after a
severe flooding or other natural
disaster
hits the bill also Al corrects some
language that Homeland Security
emergency management suggested so that
it is clear that disaster relief funding
received by this grant program only
applies to this program and is not
confused with any other disaster relief
funding that a municipality might
receive this is a very important change
to this language as
well some of you know that I've been
working on this legislation since severe
flooding aworth and other towns in our
state in July 2021 and again in July
2023 many towns experienced flooding due
to heavy rains just so you know the
bills that we have passed already in
2022 and 2023 for disaster relief the
loans um which was uh s sp49 and the
state share of payment of non- Fe
reimbursable expenditures which was s
sp402 have not even been accessible or
functional to our
municipalities rules haven't been
finished being written and the programs
haven't been put into
place let's not leave this work undone
for another year if a disaster hits we
as a state need to be prepared to help
our municipalities and give them quick
and useful tools to be able to make
roads
passable and deal with the emergency
especially if they don't have the
financial reserves
available so I'd be happy to answer any
questions and also have provided
additional information regarding
problems with SB 402 and S SP 409 and I
do have written testimony to pass
along thank you representative Aaron
we'll let you pass that to
representative kazinski
are there any questions for
representative
Aaron representative Colby thank you
madam chair uh is a municipality
required to have a FEMA or a Homeland
Security approved Hazard mitigation plan
in place to qualify for um this type of
Grant or disaster relief I don't believe
that they are required by Statute to
have any uh mitigation plans
um certainly most of them
do um and I know my town does now but
um in so far as the um disaster relief
statutes I I don't know I think in the
case of the uh The Loan program the zero
interest Loan program I believe that
they are required to have a mitigation
plan thank
you further question questions
representative Gerard thank you madam
chair uh representative Aaron and um
being from a small community um what
means would you have to try to get some
of these roads open because again I I
remember the floods from several years
ago you had some pretty heavy damage and
$25,000 doesn't go far what what would
you have for other means to be able to
thank you for your question
representative Gerard well of course a
town may have some money put away uh in
uh contingency plan funds or Road and
Bridge funds uh they may have some money
extra in their um uh fund
balance and certainly a smaller
Community like aworth where there's 850
people in a tax base that can barely
maintain the roads that they have when a
disaster hits like that it takes many
many years to recover um it's
devastating so above and beyond what
they may have I know with aworth there
were many people in our town that
volunteered their back you know their
back loader or their uh their trucks or
their
whatever whatever uh resources they had
at hand they donated to the town they
donated their time there is also um
Municipal um Mutual
aid but when a disaster hits in a
particular
area usually the towns you have mutual
Aid with are also busy trying to repair
and get their feet back on the ground as
well so it was it's kind of um it's kind
of a fluid situation you get help where
you can get help and I know that our
town also requested help from the state
and the from the do uh department where
we were able to get signage we were able
to get barriers uh on loan and things
like like that um
so let's just say there was scant help
um but certainly an infusion of cash uh
from the state would go a long way and
help the town uh pay for some of the
expenses and
um certainly uh
$25,000 kind of isn't enough in that
time and $100,000 seems to be more
reasonable
additional
questions seeing none thank you
representative Aaron appreciate it I
appreciate your time and consideration
for this
bill at this time I do not have any
additional pink cards so if there's
anyone present who wishes to
testify on this bill and has not yet had
the opportunity needed to do
so please let me know seeing
none we will report the blue sheets
thank you madam chair uh the blue sheet
today we
have three members or
three signatures uh in support zero
opposed and remote sign in is 10 in
support and zero
opposed thank you representative Gilman
and with that I will close the public
hearing on House Bill 165
okay he he has
it
head
okay
e
e e
find
the time is now 1040 and I will open the
public hearing on House Bill
173 relative to maintaining the purpose
of a petitioned warrant
article the
chair welcomes the prime sponsor
representative
sellers to introduce the Bill thank
thank you madam chair and uh committee m
members the uh I am representative John
cers from Grafton district 10 Bristol
and Bridgewater up by the Lakes Region
and uh this is my second term and I
submitted this bill and of course I
support the bill all
right it's a very simple change and I
say simple sometimes words matter right
so as if you had the bill and you were
able to read it it's all about one
sentence and what what it does it says
or it's this is all about warrant
articles and it's this case it's about a
petition warrant article many times we
go out and we go out in the around the
neighborhoods and stuff and uh we have a
petition article we want to submit and
we have to gather the 25 or more uh
votes signatures and stuff to be counted
and then we bring it into uh being voted
on and a lot of times when you get there
uh what happens is uh someone will stand
up and amend it to the point of changing
the intent of it the intent of the
petition article would be to go to the
voters to have them give an up or down
vote but a lot of times they will go to
the voters they'll actually change the
intent to actually go to the voters to
say let's study this all right let's
study this petition War
article where you've already gone out
and have done the work the 25 people or
more that have actually signed on at
that point have already realized that
this is important enough
that we should actually bring it to the
people and have them vote on it so the
first part of this bill it says you know
it says no warrant article shall be
amended to eliminate the subject matter
that's not changing of course right so
that's the subject matter so the part
that is changing
or to change the purpose of our petition
warrant article so being very specific
it's not just a warrant article that uh
the board the school board or the uh
select board may bring this is a
petition from the people so that's
that's what this is all about and uh I
can give you an
example uh where I just stated that uh
more than once uh in the district that
I'm in school district in this case uh
they have
changed petition warrant articles to be
studies and it really upsets the people
there and and upsets you know the voters
at that point point and in some cases
depending where if you if you ever been
to an sb2 type uh delivera to session uh
in some cases it's very um one-sided or
the other because especially when it
comes to school subjects they tend to
come out very strong with uh the teacher
and the staff side of schools depending
on you know what the uh warrant is all
about so in this case here you know
several times this not happen once this
is just a my district you know district
10 at this point so I'm hoping that
you'd all see see this and see how
important it is that for a petition
warrant article that we don't change the
intent of it the purpose thank
you thank you representative sers are
there questions for the prime sponsor
the chair recognizes representative
Guthrie thank you Mr chair Madam chair
and thank you representative sellers for
taking my question uh I've been a
selectman for a long time uh in my town
of Hamstead and I was selectman in mass
and I always thought this was in the uh
legislation already I I thought a
petition article was uh sacred and they
just weren't able to touch it at all uh
the 25 people plus come in asking the
question they deserve an answer without
anything to be touched to it but when
finding out that that was not the case
in fact I'm a
co-sponsor of this
article mainly because I didn't realize
this was not in the legislation and it's
something that I think uh is done in
most towns but I think we ought to make
it clear that this is the way we should
be doing business so my question is do
you
recognize the fact that uh this uh is
needed more more so because people
really don't understand what the rules
are in petition
articles uh thank you representative and
that is correct um for many many many
years in our district can you not hear
me all right many many many years in our
district we all thought that you
couldn't change the intent until uh we
actually had um The Honorable Ned Gordon
as moderator and he corrected us really
quick and say no that's not the in the
RSA so that's why I've now added it to
the RSA at this point and you're right I
mean you go into these meetings and you
think okay they can't change this intent
and you just didn't realize and really
the RSA just says you cannot eliminate
the subject matter so now it's being a
little more
specific further questions
before I recognize representative Gilman
I did want to note that when
speaking anybody here in this committee
make sure the microphone is close like
two Ines and a little bit lower because
I'm having trouble hearing people so
this is to people on the committee as
well as people um providing testimony
thank you representative Gilman thank
you thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question um I we re my
town exitor had a a petitioned article
for tax cap so the tax there was do you
want to have a tax cap of
percent is the would you say that the
subject matter is
the tax cap and the purpose is
4% or vice
versa I gota I got to really think about
that um because I I'll tell you it was
amended at the at the deliberative
session okay um tax cap part stay but
the amount changed so I I've seen an RSA
um and it may be this one or I was just
reading it this morning in this one here
um and this what is it
4013 um that this has nothing to do with
the money side so and actually let me
just see it's right here um
yeah it's right here it's it's a it says
in this case here it says an amendment
that changes the dollar amount of an
appropriation in an warrant arle shall
not be deemed uh to violate the subpar
all right so that's that's the money
side so the intent would be and what I'm
saying in your case would be that tax
cap would maybe change to a study
instead of going to the voters for a
vote that actually to accept or not
accept the tax
cap followup Madam chair yes just to
clarify what you have said um
because um you didn't use either of the
words um elim uh subject matter
or purpose in that example of creating a
study what's your question I'm sorry
didn't well my qu oh I didn't finish I
guess my question is uh if changing this
to a study committee
would what would it fall under the um
subject matter or the or the purpose
would that be the purpose that would be
the purpose because your purpose of your
petition War article is to bring it to
the voters to see if you want to approve
a tax cap that's my in so that's the
intent of that petition warrant
article what what happens is they end up
changing it saying well let's bring it
to the voters as a study to see if we
want to change that tax Gap so they're
actually changed the intent
where you were actually going to go for
a vote and now it's only a
study thank you further
questions representative
Murphy thank you madam chair thank you
representative fellows um for taking
this question I thought I'm a town
moderator I would never allow someone to
say that because that's changing to me
it's like saying Toc two Stu you already
changed the the the warrant article to
what you what what an attent is so I
would I don't
know I don't get this part of it to be
honest with you because I wouldn't
permit this at a town meeting and we're
can have one in a week or
two yeah the and and and that's what the
people would think as well but that's
not what's been happening and that's why
I am I'm asking I'm asking to be put
this in writing so now you know know
that the intent cannot be changed the
purpose because in in my district it's
happened just in the last 5 years it's
happened at least
twice additional
questions representative
grund thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question so we had a
similar similar situation we had a
proposed tax cap and we actually had
discussion with our legal council about
whether a tax cap is a dollar amount or
a purpose and could it be changed or not
it there was an amendment made and there
was a discussion so it could get a
little muddy of when it becomes to
something very specific of that so the
clarification
of changing the purpose would have made
this difficult potentially so I don't
know how you would see again that tax
cap
piece um as per purpose versus amount do
you have a thought on that so when I'm
when I'm thinking through this more is
the subject matter really is the tax cap
the the dollar amount is the percentage
right so you know you go to a delivered
assession and still change that three or
five or 8% whatever you wanted to this
has nothing to do with that the tax cap
itself is is really the subject matter
all right but the intent is to bring
that petitioned warrant article to the
voters for an up or down vote not to
make that petition warrant article a
study and that's what's been happening
in our
case the chair recognizes representative
majori thank you madam chair chairwoman
and thank you for being here um while I
while I think this makes a whole a whole
lot of sense I'm curious uh the newshire
municipal Association has written on
this subject matter many many times
before this type of bill has been before
us many times before and suddenly I find
myself unable to recall whether intent
or purpose is the correct word here and
I'm
wondering I mean being an English major
I know the difference between the
words I'm wondering if we it it should
it be purpose or should it be
intent and thank you representative and
that's a a good question and honestly I
went back and forth several times and I
I went and asked a few people at that
point and I initially had the word
intent they thought purpose was the
better way to go all right and so that's
why it landed on purpose but you know
you're right about the words I mean
they're so close but they are a little
different thank
you additional questions
representative
stavis thank you madam chair and thank
you representative sers for taking my
question um going back to these two
words they are very different words
would you be amenable to just including
purpose I are you saying to amend the
word purpose to intent to just include
purpose and not intent that's that's all
that's here in the in the bill right now
is just Pur my my apologies that's okay
my AP nope that's
right the chair recognizes
representative Colby for a
question thank you madam chair um we
have many sb2 communities um that are
not um going into their deliberative
sessions uh
uh they aren't having them you know
until even the end of February um April
May
uh would there be consideration for
extending the effective date of this
statute um so that commun uh communities
residents uh election officials uh such
as some Town
moderators um would be have an
opportunity to kind of absorb
uh what the new language means to them
yeah thank you representative and that's
a good point I mean we do have some Tom
meetings in in May you know in this case
so no I'm not against doing that and if
the committee sees to put that as a July
1st 2025 that may be a better date and
that way we don't have to worry about
the elections and this spring at
all okay thank you
thank you for the question at this point
I'd like to add a point of
clarification so it says the the
effective date is 60 days after its
passage this bill will come out of this
committee it will go to the house floor
for a vote then it needs to go to the
Senate which is sometime after
crossover needs to go through their
process to the Senate house floor then
to the governor's desk so this um
probably if it gets that far far will
not make it to the governor's desk until
sometime during the summer July so very
good point Thank
you further questions representative
Gilman okay this is going to sound kind
of silly but I'm I'm uh like others
stuck on the words of U subject matter
versus petition and I'm beginning to
understand or can find my examples one
way or the other but I just wanted to
verify with you um in a town which I
don't know if it was a official ballot
Town um was a a warrant article to
change a petitioned article to change
the color of their uh police
cars and um it was amended to change the
color of their police cars to purple or
some other odd color would that fall
under if the subject matter was painting
the police cars but the purpose was
painting them blue instead of purple
would that not be
allowed thank you for the question and
and I'm not the expert here on that but
to me that's still all the subject
matter you know if you if if the
petitioners brought for that warrant out
forth they're trying to just say we want
the police cars painted blue all right
so to me that's the subject matter the
the intent of it is to say now instead
of bringing it to the voters and asking
for a vote on that we want to bring it
to the voters to study that to see if we
should paint it blue to paint them blue
so there's still they're changing the
whole intent of the warrant article to
the point of it it's it becoming it's
becoming something else subject matter
doesn't change all right nor does the
Dollar you know the dollar amount could
because it has nothing to do with this
so
um the only way I can explain it I I
mean as the uh representative over here
it said you know he would never would
have changed any warrant doic he would
have left it but in our district the
moderator thought it was no it that was
permissible to do it's not in RSA thank
you forther questions the chair
recognizes representative
Walker um forgive me for my ignorance
I'm from a city not from a town are
there different kinds of Warrant off
articles well my say the warrant there
are warrant articles that are submitted
by the say the select board or the
school board but then the uh the people
can also bring forth a warrant article
but they need to gather so many
signatures right to show that hey they
got some people that are very interested
in this
followup yes would would a better way to
attack this was to put the language that
you can't amend a petitioned warrant
article that way it's from the people
right from the people to the so the
selectman can't change the intent or
change the title to deceive voters at
town
meeting
um I'm not sure because you still want
to I'm not sure on that I I don't know
if that's I just don't
know additional questions representative
Murphy when you CH that would have to be
done by an an amendment to that warrant
article and I would not permit as a
moderator that type and I've seen it
before I would never permit that type of
a an amendment to that warrant article
because you are changing the warrant
article you're taking it from something
and making a two-way study that's
changing the intent of the Warren
article it's not changing the color of
the of a vehicle it's not changing the
dollar amount it's changing the attend
of the Warren article to
me I don't know that that's that's like
common sense but I don't know you know
that's exactly what happened you're
right it does come through as an
amendment you're right and I wouldn't
permit that Amendment and I think that
you know and anybody here when town
meeting if you go to town meeting please
member shall suspend rep representative
Murphy This is a time for questions andw
answers not to um comment back towards
the the witness would do did you have a
question in there that that might have
been a lead in but was there a question
coming that was already been answered
thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you
representative sers thank you madam
chair next theair calls Mr Brian
Lewis welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you my name is Brian
Lewis I live in Alexandria I'm
representing myself and I favor this
bill I've been at meetings Town meetings
where the venue is packed by a special
interest group and the special interest
group will hijack the
process they will subvert the
will of the electorate by trying to get
the warrant article changed typically
they will change it to a study group and
if they're successful in doing this the
stud study group if they study it at all
they invariably come back doing the
bidding of the special interest group
this is not how the process is supposed
to work this bill is very much
needed uh the the verbs that come to
mind uh Mr English major
representative uh the study the special
interest groups they will subvert hijack
emasculate eviscerate all kinds of
things that it's their way of preventing
the uh public the the electorate from
voting on a warrant article that was
properly lawfully submitted and that
should not even
happen
uh sometimes these venues are filled
with
students and what kind of a civics
lesson are we giving to students by
saying okay this is how you get what you
want you come in and you hijack the
process that's that's that's wrong it
shouldn't be happening at all I'm
certainly glad to hear that as a
moderator you wouldn't allow this but
you're you might be the only one there
are moderators who do I've seen it and I
think this bill is a step in the right
direction in preventing that in the
future thank you very much Madame
chairman
thank you sir will are you able to take
questions I will
questions representative
Dolan thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question isn't it is
it not true that in these uh venues that
happen every
spring
that we heard we we heard a resident
moderator uh talk about what things that
can happen but isn't it true that
between the moderator and the town
attorney which should probably be
present also that these types of things
should are avoided in that way so that
the uh the meeting isn't hijacked by uh
people who uh who come to the
meeting
well I'd like to think it should work
that way but I have not seen it work
that way
if we put it into the law that says that
they can't that makes it
explicit follow up
yes so the the question that that I have
you know as as as we are now being asked
to get involved uh is is would it would
it not be better that these type of
questions uh are determined by the local
authorities to to use the legal uh
expert expertise that they have between
the moderator and the town attorney to
resolve these rather than to do them
what whatever they think might be the
best uh way out of this given that this
is happening and this is what the law
would prevent I would say
no uh local expertise is fine but if the
law says they can't do it they can't do
it and right now they are doing it and
it needs to be stopped thank you
representative stavis is recognized for
a question thank you madam chair and
thank you representative for taking my
question can you tell me who these
special interest groups are and what the
process is that they use to as in your
words emasculate these
proceedings well special interest group
can be anybody who wants the warrant
article defeated
and the way they try to do this is by
getting it changed into a study group
that's not the purpose of the warrant
article and by getting it made into a
study group there is zero chance that
the warrant article as proposed is going
to be
passed so that's how they hijack the
process they're preventing the
electorate from voting on the warrant
article as it was submitted
further questions representative
Walker I go back to my first question
from the first person how about uh not
allowing any edits or amendments to a
petition warrant article wouldn't that
uh suffice because I've seen it happen
in a neighboring
town and it was a warrant petition
warrant AR article
asking the selectman to to be to resign
it was changed by the Town Administrator
and the town attorney rewarded so it
didn't quite ask that and it deceived
the public and it passed that they would
stay so I see how words can be
manipulated from the town Administration
or special interest group so my previous
question about should it if it's a
petition warrant article should it not
not be owed to have amendments would
that
suffice well the point of the petition
article might be uh as as described in
the uh in the the bill if it changes the
dollar amount that would be an amendment
to the petition article but it would not
change the purpose or the
intent uh I don't see that as a reason
as a thing that should
be eliminated I think that that's a if
amendments if they don't change the
intent I don't see a problem with that
it's when they try to make an amendment
to prevent the Warren article from
getting uh as as proposed as intended uh
from from the electorate voting on
it thank
you the chair recognizes representative
Murphy thank you madam
chair you talk about the special
interest groups are they voters or
non-voters sometimes they're
non-voters but uh well for instance
sometimes a moderator will allow these
non voters to
speak at this at the
meeting um if they're not voting and and
they're not even of legal age I don't
see that they should be
speaking but they they certain shouldn't
be trying to modify something that
they're not going to be voting on not
qualified to vote
on but I've seen
both thank you further
questions seeing none thank you sir
thank you for hearing my testimony do
you have anything written I do not okay
except my notes to speak from okay thank
you the final pink card that I have for
this bill is Mr bro
Dees oh I like this card you guys put
out uh my name is Brody Dees I represent
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
we are a um volunteering membership
organization nonpartisan nonprofit that
represents the municipalities in cities
in the state of New Hampshire and we are
opposed to the bill as it's currently
written um
our position is that um all waren
articles should be treated the same
whether they're petitioned or they come
from the governing body and to treat um
to have two different classifications
for how um at a deliberative session
they're treated could not only get
confusing but kind of takes away the
power of the public body to amend make
changes or even to the governing body to
try to make a warrant article whether
it's petitioned um or not um legal which
can become an issue that um you guys
have touched upon with some questions
um we believe public body should have a
right to amend like the legislature when
a bill is introduced as a committee you
have a right to change that bill um to
make it legal to make it work with
current legislative language and um and
the entire legislature could even
disagree with your recommendation or
amendments and adopt its own position as
a house before it goes on to the next
chamber
um part of the reason for the ter
current language um in front of us on
the uh line three where it says no
warrant article shall be amended to
eliminate the subject matter um the
legislature took action after sb2 passed
and towns adopted it to make it so then
um governing bodies or even the public
bodies couldn't just amend a petition
warn article to delete the entire
article except for the first three words
um which became somewhat of an issue and
it sounds strange I know but that had
happened in some towns so that is the
purpose for subject matter that you
wouldn't have these um at deliberative
session you wouldn't have the voters
getting rid of the entire subject matter
um so then essentially the warn article
would be null and voided as if nothing
was ever
introduced um there are times where at a
deliberative session uh changes need to
be made to make a warrant article
petitioned or not legal um sometimes
petitioners um you know not everyone in
your community is a lawyer not everyone
always understands um you know the
process but they want to be involved and
they want to see a change in their
community and sometimes as uh as a
representative Dolan mentioned your
Town's moderator and your legal counsel
and your governing bodies ultimately
with the consent of those at
deliberative the public body need to
make a change so then the Warren warrant
article can actually be legal and
implemented in the community um
something this bill doesn't necessarily
take into account is um that there are
times where there are changes that the
petitioner may want and um it might not
be entirely in line with what you know
quote purpose is defined as um so you
could actually limit the petitioners or
those at the public public body their
right to change it so then it's more in
line with what their quote purpose would
be um there's also the issue of no
petitioner attends so um purpose can't
be deciphered you might get a petition
warn article in the whole public body
and it has happens sometimes in
communities we've seen where the whole
public body and the governing bodies and
the moderator and legal counsel are just
confused with what the ultimate intent
would be of a petition warn article um
also purpose is not clearly defined as
we've heard today A lot of people are
kind of talking about what's a better
word intent or purpose well uh my
understanding is purpose is why or the
ultimate goal of a petition warrant
article so one could argue that if you
put in a petition warrant article for
say we talked about tax caps that
changing the percentage that would
change the purpose of that petition warn
article you'd be changing the ultimate
percentage so the ultimate goal of the
warn article intent is how or
determination to achieve that goal so um
intent actually might be not the best
word to use because the intent would be
throughout the process you have an
intent but your purpose is what you want
your outcome to be Mr Dees uh you've
exceeded the three minutes could you
wrap it up quickly um my last point was
just going to be that um the current
language allows the flexibility for
governing bodies with consent of their
public bodies at deliberative to make uh
to treat all petition sorry to treat all
warn articles the same and to respect
the process and the will of the voters
um and with that I can take any
questions thank you
questions the chair recognizes
representative
majori thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you for taking my question
um the the petition warrant article is
debatable as far as I know by the by the
body is the body only the voting members
of the town or is it a public public
meeting open to anyone where anyone can
speak to the petition warrant article
the only people who can vote on the
waren Articles and to vote on amendments
to the Warren articles petitioned or not
are those who are residents duly
registered and who can you know qualify
to vote um they are public meetings open
to the public so anyone can attend
whether it's press whether it's people
under the age of 18 but they are not
allowed to vote so it's a free speech
issue you can't deny them access and you
can't deny them their ability to speak
uh during the process is my
understanding the chair recognizes
representative Dolan thank you madam
chair is it the nh's position that that
an
amendment at the town meeting uh can be
to amend the the uh article to zero
amount is that is that a legal uh
option the warrant article right to to
amend the the amount of the warant
article to a zero not not just the first
three words but the entire article to
zero um I wouldn't call it our position
but I think I
think I'd have to double check but I
think legally yes the public body could
zero out a warrant article or change you
know even if they couldn't zero it out
they could change the dollar amount to
$1 effectively making it you know kind
of N and void so if you wanted to spend
for example a bridge and you know people
decided they didn't want to replace said
bridge and they decided to change the
worn article amount to $1 obviously if
it costs half a million dollars to build
the bridge you know you're not going to
be able to build it with $1 I don't know
what kind of contract it would take a
dollar to rebuild Municipal bridge to to
the state and federal standards so thank
you the chair recognizes representative
stavis for a question thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question is it any nh's position that
under public meeting laws there is no
such thing as an outside interest or a
special interest since everyone is
allowed to speak if not to
vote I don't think we have a position
per se but I think legally um anyone who
is allowed to access a public meeting is
allowed to access a public meeting and
only those who are duly registered to
vote are allowed to participate in the
votes at Del liberative session
so I guess you know as long as they're a
resident they're not a special interest
group and if they have an interest in
attending and watching the meeting then
they do like any other citizen or
resident or uh human
being further questions represented
France is an outside
interest um allowed to bring forth an
amendment even though they don't vote on
it
anybody who's a member of the public
body who's duly registered to vote and
allowed to participate in deliberative
session is allowed to bring forward an
amendment and has to be duly seconded um
so it's not a special interest it would
be a resident of the Town who's allowed
you know who showed up show that they're
registered to vote you know registered
to attend and everything typically they
give you a little placard at least in my
town we get a w in the year on it I
always save mine for every deliberative
session just so I can keep track how
many I've been to and that's what we Ed
to ultimate
um vote so they do keep track of that
the moderators and the town clerks um
so further
questions seeing
none we will report out the blue sheet
oh no yes thank you that's the last pink
card all right let's hold for one second
no you're you're good so I I did want to
say that is there anyone present who
wishes to speak on this bill who has not
yet had the opportunity to do
so okay seeing none we will report out
the blue
sheet thank you madam chair on today's
blue sheet there was one register for
support and one and two for opposition
uh in the remote signin there were five
in support and two in
opposition thank you representative
Gilman with that I will close the public
hearing on House Bill 17
73 is this all
them you want to
start so we're doing really good on time
and at this point I will open up the
public hearing on House Bill 348
relative to the eligibility for local
assistance with us today we have
representative rhs she's is the prime
sponsor of the bill welcome to Municipal
and County
government thank you madam
chairwoman good morning committee
members happy new
year so I come in front of you this
morning with House Bill
348 and before I get into the logistics
of the bill I would like to give a a
little disclosure that I have been
meeting with um several of The Advocates
that have interest in the bill and I
have agreed to some wording changes
that have not yet been written and at
the discretion of the chairwoman I will
make these amendments as promised and
you know give them to her and if she
feels that it is necessary for me to
come back before you guys have your
executive session and discuss them any
further I would welcome the opportunity
to do that um otherwise I you know trust
her to go ahead and explain the the
change that would be made after I leave
here this morning Madam
chair so house bow 348 um is intent is
to say that the
beneficiary that is receiving local
welfare funds lives in the said town
that they are receiving the funds
from so New Hampshire and its Infinite
Wisdom with their local control has
establish this local
welfare because at the time it was my
understanding that the people that live
in the town know best of the Town
economics and the town's Commerce it was
intended to be neighbors helping
neighbors over the F last few years
since I've been a representative I have
witnessed the local Town's welfare
budget have just grown
exponentially everybody keeps on saying
that there is you know this this crisis
this economy crisis they're talking
about the inflation everybody says we
need to do something but nobody really
ever steps back and does something that
I have actually seen this is an attempt
to actually bring the local welfare
budgets back to the local
level So within the welfare RSA 165
towns are allowed to set
guidelines however Within These
guidelines there is this list of
non-negotiable items that must be
included and one of the things that it
says is that if a person appears in
front of the local welfare officer that
he or she shall me shall be relieved
whether or not they are a resident of
that town that is what I am attempting
to change
today so I also when I changed this I
was very specific when it said the word
resident to keep that for this chapter
resident for the purpose of this chapter
because you cannot pay me enough to talk
about residency when it comes to
election law so for the purpose of this
chapter what residency actually means
and I had put in some criteria which
would be a car registration a copy of a
signed lease um maybe utility bill uh
one of the agreed changes was an
oversight on my part I should have put
in there
about a government issued ID so that is
something that you know reasonably I'm
going to put that change another thing
that was discussed was the addition
of other proof of residency whether that
was a social worker a written statement
ATT testing that they have seen this
person live in the town um maybe
something that says that you know this
person is self-paying at a hotel but you
know I have seen them actually you know
partake in
community I would like to leave that up
to the governing body right so I'm
trying very hard to keep this a local
control so if the governing body wants
to
adopt this up to x amount of days which
we'll get to because that's been
requested to be
changed so if the governing body Madam
chair wants to say you know we want you
to have to live here for x amount of
days days and in addition to this
minimal requirements we are also going
to accept these other forms of
residency that is something that we were
discussing again I would like it to be
left to the local municipality to be
able to vote on what they would like
those changes to
be so last session Senate Bill 110
passed and my understanding is that was
going to try to help relieve some of the
confusion when it comes to local welfare
so if a a person goes to person lives in
town a and then they go to town B for
whatever reason and they and they are
you know given some welfare
dollars what was happening is some
towns some towns are saying hey wait a
minute you know town a owes us money
because we provided assistance to to
this
person so in my opinion what was meant
to help clear up some confusion has
actually created a lot of confusion and
it's actually creating some animosity
between towns so because you're allowed
to make your own guidelines town a may
not allow for certain expenses that
maybe Town B does allow for so now when
the person goes to that second Town it
could be that those expenses are allowed
which they weren't originally which made
the person maybe not qualify in that
town or additionally it could just be
that that particular welfare officer
maybe they maybe they didn't check maybe
they just maybe they're just not as
sticklers for the rules as other people
are so what's LED that to be is Town B
is now saying hey you you know you owe
us money because we provided relief to
this
person towns don't really necessarily
like that now I I know that that was the
intention of that was meant to be good
and I've learned this morning I might
not be totally understanding it and
that's okay but the point is is we're
back to there's confusion right because
people just understand it to be
different and I don't know the solution
to
that so some of the other
changes that that were discussed
was having the having the wording be
special consideration and decision and
decision consideration shall be provided
for
non-residents um reporting domestic
violence or human trafficking situations
within their own town of origin as many
of you know I I'm a staunch Fighter for
for anybody that is in a domestic
violence situation or a person that has
experienced sexual assault I I know from
doing this job that nobody has ever
called the local welfare office and said
I'm I'm preparing to leave an abuser can
I can you put me in a hotel like that
that has never happened and it's also
the understanding that that's not how
that happens if anything these are these
are pre-arranged the person's going to
go to a safe house Etc
I I'm willing to put that in there I
don't think that it's going to matter
either way but if it's a safeguard that
that is something I'm not I'm not going
to fight over that that's that's fine um
there was also a a request
for um the additional wording that you
know if a person you know shows up and
they're not a resident that the the
overseer is able to you know provide
this temporary
relief again I think that should be up
to the governing body if they want to
make those exceptions they can certainly
make those exceptions but I think that
should be up to them I don't think that
the state should say this is what you
have to
do so you know sometimes you have you
have Bad actors right so I had an
example
of a landlord rent it out an apartment
the the the young woman only lived there
for a few days she called up and said
hey I need you to pay my rent I said
what what and she wasn't she wasn't able
to pay the rent and when I asked her why
did you sign this lease I'm very
confused can you help me understand why
why did you even sign the lease and she
said well because I needed a place to
live and I knew you had to help me so I
called up the landlord and said do you
realize that she's not she doesn't she
has no intentions of paying this and he
said well yes but I told her to come to
you because I know that you have to help
that that's not okay right that the
people that are coming up with with this
t with these tax dollars some of them
are working two jobs some of them are
retired working two jobs this is real
people with real budgets that are
struggling to come up with their tax
dollars I don't think that it's too much
to ask at the very least a person that
signs a lease is able to at least live
there for one month and and be able to
to pay that that's why I wanted to make
this as much local control as
possible representative rhods um yes
you're approaching eight minutes and we
we were
you give me three minutes Madam chair
three minutes additional no no no I I I
said did you give me three minutes I was
giving you five um we have 11 pink cards
here so if you have additional
information you'd like to share maybe
that will come out in questions and
answers or you could um provide
written in
testimony due to the due due to our time
constraint so can
let's go into questions and answers and
maybe
um Madam chair if I may I I was actually
going to conclude with okay I I'll make
those Amendment changes and I'll give
them to you and let you tell me how you
would like to handle that fine and
you're willing to take questions yes
thank you questions for the
representative the chair recognizes
representative
Colby thank you madam chair um um I
appreciate that uh you have amendments
that are forthcoming my questions are
based on the bill as
introduced um you touched on victims of
Domestic and Sexual
Violence uh they often find themselves
in extremely dire
circumstances uh they flee abusers uh it
is not
planned um necessarily uh they depart
with their children maybe uh minimal
belongings
many of the individuals have already
been deprived of their
autonomy um and their financial
Independence so they're not going to
appear on a car registration they're not
going to appear on a lease uh or a
utility bill and they may not have the
ID when they
leave um these folks would struggle to
provide um the proof of residence that
is
stipulated um how would you propose that
these or other vulnerable individuals
uh could obtain assistance and
support um if they lack this necessary
documentation thank you for the
question If a person is in the situation
that you described and that I had
described The Advocates is an example of
the
Coalition they help those families to
first of all get themselves back on
their feet they're usually provided a
safe house if not an out andout
apartment on their own and I do know
that from my understanding working with
the Coalition that they actually have
like a housing Advocate that helps them
to
reestablish reestablish
residency so that they they are provided
with the assistance that that is
absolutely
needed um I'll allow a a quick followup
but I would like to remind members that
make every attempt to frame your
question very
succinctly and avoid long leadings
followup um if they're if they are
establishing residency once they leave
the house then it wouldn't meet your
90day the 90-day requirement in the
statute
correct representative I I don't know
the answer to that I think that you're
assuming that just because of person's
leaving a situation if I'm understanding
that they have to go to the local
welfare office that might not even be
the case they may be they may be set up
with their Advocate to where they don't
they don't need to go and if they did I
made a provision for
that further questions the chair
recognizes representative
Guthrie thank you madam chair to build
on the previous
question
If a person
uh under this system they without the
with the 90 days so that you would would
why do we have local welfare at all if
we have all these other sources of help
why don't we just do away with local
welfare representative I I'm certain
that I can't answer that question I
think that would be a a state level I I
can guarantee you without any doubt if I
wrote a law to completely abolish RSA
165 that would probably go over like a
hot
rock followup Madam chair yes isn't this
bill doing actually doing that with if
you put the 90 days on you the
limitation on of the people that you
would serve with that 90day residency
would be probably
nil so don't you think that this bill is
actually doing what I suggested and that
was to doway with local
welfare thank you for the for the
follow-up question representative I
disagree I I don't think that this is
doing that at all if you actually look
at the
RSA there is a plethora of services that
are available I was suggesting that the
person receiving the funds live in the
town that is
providing the assistance right thank you
thank you for your your answers further
questions representative
grund thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um so it's
kind of a a two-parter so are you saying
for 90 days they wouldn't receive any
assistance at all from a prior town or a
town that they might move into thank you
for the question so for clarification
the 90 days is going to be changed there
was suggestion to make it 30 I suggested
possibly 60 I had get was given some
information from somebody I met with
earlier that we actually may have to
make it 30
um but to answer your question
the there are there are services that
are available to people without having
to go to the local welfare office a lot
of times people don't like to reach out
to those Services because it's a little
bit encumbersome but it's encumbersome
for a reason um the way I wrote it is
not to be able to receive you know
receive this was like you know rent
possibly um but keep in mind the way the
law is written now it is you know the
prior
town the the prior town would basically
be responsible but the way the law is
also written is you're not allowed the
welfare officer is not allowed to
suggest to the person to go back to that
prior town it's a little bit conv
convoluted so what's happening is towns
are getting angry at each other other
because there's this question of who who
is responsible who's responsible to pay
I'm I'm trying to clear that up so if
Town B did not want to they want you to
actually be resident to receive those
Services they would actually have that
option where now they don't have that
option at
all kind do very quick followup quick
followup um so a family that might
become homeless is a quick situation
Unfortunately they would have might they
might move immediately because they're
now homeless they're not able to
my concern is you'd have to wait now it
might be 30 days which the amendment
would would be probably preferable but
they'd have to wait to be able to ask
for help was that thank you for the
question one of the suggestions was to
put and again this is what I wanted to
leave up to the to the voting body or
the governing body was whether or not
they they can still apply but according
to the guidelines if this was adopted
they wouldn't qualify for those
guidelines Madam chair if I may when I
wrote this
it was just written like this I've since
learned that Massachusetts and Maine
have changed their Massachusetts changed
their right the shelter to be 30 days
and Maine has changed their their hotel
cost I believe it's $1,300 a
month that this goes back to what local
welfare was meant to be right so if
we're going to ask the people to come up
with this
money I fear what's going to happen is
people from Massachusetts are going to
say say will go up to New Hampshire or
people from Maine are going to say go
over to New Hampshire and that is
certainly not local control or what this
was ever intended to
be the chair recognizes representative
Gilman thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question uh this is
amending um RSA 165 col
1-c um but I'm sorry 165 col 1 um but
1-c uh five provides for municipalities
to communicate and coordinate assistance
options how is that not
adequate thank you for the question that
that was what I was explaining that past
last year which was Senate Bill 110
where it's creating confusion over
exactly what the municipalities are
allowed ask other municipalities to do
and when I spoke with the gentleman from
The Welfare
Association he's able to explain that
and explain why it actually why the
confusion actually does
exist additional
questions representative
stavis thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question in RSA 165
section 2 B There is a disqualification
for certain Property Transfers which
would appear to completely bar the
hypothetical that you suggested of
people coming from Maine or
Massachusetts or Vermont or wherever and
I wonder if you're familiar with that
section
representative if the chairman would lie
you to read it it it's not anything that
I discuss with The
Advocates I'm happy to read it it's very
short
quickly no person who is otherwise
eligible for assistance under this
chapter shall receive such assistance if
he has made an assignment transfer a
conveyance of property for the purpose
of rendering himself eligible for such
assistance within three years
immediately preceding his application
for such
assistance representative I would
suggest that you that you talk with the
the experts behind me about it because
my understanding is you're not allowed
to it it says it right in there whether
or not he or she resides in the town
the chair recognizes representative
majori thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you representative for taking my
question and being here today um by
creating another definition of Resident
have you is it possible that you have
created a situation where somebody can
be viewed as being two different types
of people I'm I'm I'm defined as a res
now under this but in 2 years from now
how do I change back to being a resident
under
21 uh colon 6 I I I I'm just curious if
we have created a level of
residency which
may hurt somebody hurt not physically
but you know create a problem thank you
for the question I I actually disagree
so I was very specific to say for
welfare purposes for local welfare
purposes and if I may add representative
that was also a suggestion from The
Advocates to make it be specific to that
section you're
welcome further
questions representative
Gilman thank you madam chair and thank
you representative um I know that it is
the duty of every town and City to
provide uh welfare Assistance or
assistance to people in need um but and
line items may have to change to do that
if if I have a line item in my budget
for
$445,000 welfare relief and I have
requests for
50,000 um and the town's budget is tight
wouldn't I wouldn't it be make it more
flexible for the town with less money
to get assistance themselves from
another
town um which goes back to the lines you
want to
change I I'm just saying I'm asking um
wouldn't it be more flexible to provide
the needs for those uh who need
it representative I I'm sorry but I'm
very confused by your question
I I'm sorry I what I'm sorry I I'm just
saying the the the way 1651 C is written
now with the communicate and coordinate
assistance if one town runs out of money
in their welfare budget um could they
not coordinate and communicate with
another town that provides that can
assist uh the
needy thank you for the question I I do
not believe that one town can go to
another town and ask them to help with
their welfare budget line I I don't
think that that's possible to do
the that Senate bill that you're talking
about was meant
for was meant for if a person is is
receiving
funds from being in another town that
they might not necessarily reside in and
it gives an option for that second town
to be able to be reimbursed for funds
that were made available to the to the
person I I don't see how it could
possibly be where I could ask a town the
town of Swansea as an example could say
to the town of Troy
can you give us money for our welfare
budget line I I I don't see how that
could work but I maybe somebody behind
me would better understand I I don't
think that's I don't think that's
realistic are there any other questions
for the prime sponsor seeing none thank
you madam chair I just have a this is
from one of my towns it was supposed to
come that wasn't able to yes thank you
please pass that to
representative kazinski kazinski thank
you
e
so at this point I just conferred with
the um ranking member U with regards to
the hearing on this bill right now in my
hand I have 11 pink cards it's almost 10
of 12 and it's difficult to predict how
many people wish to speak on a bill and
it's important that we hear your input
so the ranking member and myself have um
agreed that we will get through the pink
cards we were going to take lunch around
noon and then we were to come back at 1
to continue with hearings our plan now
is to hear everybody that's signed up
and anybody that wishes to speak on this
bill then I will look at the time if we
have enough time to take a decent lunch
break um we will do so and come back at
1 if we do not we will work through
lunch we will proceed with hearings on
Two Bills starting at
1:00 and then after the second bill that
is the public hearing that is scheduled
at
1:20 we will then take a break and at
which time after we will come back and
exec the bills that we heard last week
so that's the
plan so at this um point I would like to
call Ms Holly
stens please state your name who you
represent and your position on the bill
and as a
reminder we I I announced at the
beginning of the day that I would permit
3 minutes we're going to stick to that
if you can do it in under three that
would be great and I would also like to
remind subsequent uh speakers to please
do not repeat again it's a random order
here we want to hear what you have to
say but we also need to be mindful of
the schedule and other bills that are
scheduled to be heard so try to keep
track of what was said please come for
the record state your name Etc say I
agree with the previous speakers and add
anything in addition cuz yeah we want a
um a composite of of input and not to
repeat things thank
you thank you chair um chair and the
committee members um good after good
morning still my name is Holly Stevens
I'm the director of public policy at
Nami New Hampshire the National Alliance
on Mental Illness Nami New Hampshire is
a Grassroots organization whose mission
is to improve the lives of all people
affected by mental illness and suicide
through support education and advocacy
and I'm here today to speak in
opposition to House Bill
348 despite the apparent intent of this
bill to protect municipalities from
having to pay for um loc local welfare
for individuals who may not live in
their towns it could have some severe
unintended consequences for folks
experiencing mental
illness um especially those folks that
are leaving treatment facilities or
jails I just wanted to call folks
attention today and I'll be very brief
because I know that you're behind
schedule to people leaving designated
receiving facilities those are folks
that were involuntarily admitted to
those hospitals did not have a choice
about what hospital they were going to
and could be there for months if not
years when they are discharged they are
discharged to the street to wherever
they were the hospital they were in and
they're not going to have any proof that
they have been there other than their
hospital records and if they are
discharged and need local assistance
they have absolutely not a single town
in the state of New Hampshire to go to
if this bill were to pass the other
thing that I wanted to bring to
attention to the committee is we have
heard from a mom of an adult young man
who has a severe mental illness Ness who
was recently released from Valley Street
jail after being there for a year he was
found not competent to stand trial and
was never restored within that year long
period that the state allows he was
released with three days worth of
medication at of Valley Street jail and
if this were to pass and Manchester were
to adopt
these the elements of this bill then
that young man could not go to City Hall
in Manchester and ask for assistance
with his
medication which would then potentially
lead to him having more symptoms of his
mental illness and could result in him
being re-incarcerated again or
hospitalized so I just asked for your
consideration of the populations that
this could impact um and for these
reasons Nami New Hampshire is opposed to
this bill and I'm happy to take any
questions that the committee may
have thank you Miss Stevens questions
representative
kazinski so prior to incarceration or uh
hospitalization did these folks have
residency
somewhere most of them did but then they
would have lost their tency and if you
lose your tency you no longer have a
valid lease that you can use to prove a
residency if they're hospitalized sorry
madam chair followup yes if they're
hospitalized just for my edification are
they able to vote by absentee
ballot I do not know I can look into
that for you and get back to you on that
if that would help thank you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony and you please follow up yes I
will to the committee with that
information thank
you next the chair calls Mr Mike
York welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you madam
chair my name is Mike York I'm the
chairman of the Swansea Richmond Troy
Republican committee I also sit on the
Swansea planning board Capital
Improvement program and the fire station
Advisory Board I I'm here today in
strong support of H 348 this bill
provides that
municipalities May establish a residency
requirement for up to 90 days I guess
that's now going to change for local
assistance now no one wants to deny
assistance to those that are in
need municipalities have limited funds
and bear all of the costs with the state
giving us
none Swansea has made up of five
Villages one town right now we have been
very good about this lowincome uh
housing that we have experienced we have
four in my side of town on West we have
four residents uh four apartment
buildings or low income buildings we
have two senior
centers apartments on the north side of
town we have two seniors and one being
built it's going to increase our
population of over 500
um the property the property taxes that
are collected from these are not going
to cover the cost of school they're not
going to cover the cost of an added
police we're going to need which are
very difficult as you know to find right
now fire uh Etc and also the local
assistance that we have to provide I do
not think it's difficult to ask that
they actually we pay for
residents now the exceptions I've just
heard that can be worked out there
certain people don't fall through the
cracks property taxes have gone Skyhigh
in almost every community in the
area and senior citizens uh veterans may
lose their
homes because they can't afford the
property tax that's what I'm hearing
from my people now Swansea is lucky as
veterans in Swansea a bit little bit
luckier because we get some good
benefits from our
town so I pay back my town by
volunteering my
services I am in strong support of this
because I think the property taxes they
need to have for we need relief from our
property taxes and that's the only way
we're going to get it to make sure that
we are actually paying for those
citizens that are in our towns thank you
I can take questions if you want thank
you Mr York questions
the chair recognizes representative
stavis thank you m Madam chair and thank
you for taking my question what
percentage of swansea's um annual budget
is allocated or is used for public
assistance I don't know at this point
but I I believe I'll have one of the U
uh Town Administrator might be able to
provide that answer uh but I know it's
it's uh grown quite a bit in the last
year the last number I heard at a
selectboard meeting I attended was like
almost $300,000 like
2886 I
believe and that's out of a budget of
about uh little about a little over
eight
million further
questions seeing none thank you Mr York
do you have written testimony I don't at
this time okay thank you
so next I will call Ms Rebecca sky and
following that I will be calling Mr
Michael
branley welcome to Municipal and County
government hello thank you my name is
Rebecca Scot I and I am the executive
director for the New Hampshire State
Commission on Aging uh I believe this is
the first time I'm providing testimony
before you I just as a brief
introduction to the commission the
commission was created during the 2019
legislative session to advise the
governor and general court on issues
related to Aging in response to the
rapid transformational permanent
demographic shift our state is going
through to an older age population so um
with that said the commission advises
against uh this particular bill hb3
48 um the commission would like to call
your attention to um The Landmark
Supreme Court cases Shiro versus Thomas
and uh Sans versus row and other CL case
law which s uh suggest that residency
requirements for welfare assistance are
generally considered unconstitutional to
not deny uh welfare benefits solely
based on the length of a time a person
has resided in a local essentially
penalizes an individual for exercising
the right to travel and does not provide
equal protection I will say that the
commission began looking into this issue
um out of concern for the increasing
percentage of older adults falling
falling into poverty and even
homelessness um the census bureau's
official poverty rate increased from 6.2
to
7.9% between 2019 and uh 2022 in the 65
plus prop
population um the Census Bureau
supplemental po poverty measure a
measure some feels more accurate as it
adjust for local cost was
14.4% in 2022 for granite sters age 65
higher than the same measure for grite
Staters 18 to 64 which was
88.4% and data from the New Hampshire
coalition to end homelessness 2024
annual report uh indicates that 21 um
over 21% of New Hampshire's homeless
population in 2023 was aged 55 and older
this is an increase of 12.5%
over 2022 figures and
23.4% since 2019 it is the most rapidly
growing uh homeless population and since
um pictures speak a thousand World words
I just want to direct you to the back of
this uh testimony um there's a a um a
nice little graph that shows um poverty
rates for the 65 plus population in New
Hampshire by County at the top and and
the bottom graph shows the rapid uh
transformational demographic shift that
I spoke about thank thank you for your
time thank you Miss Sky questions oh are
you willing to take questions absolutely
okay the chair recognizes representative
grund thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um my
question is do you believe based on some
of the data that you were speaking to
and have in your uh your letter to us
that it would eliminate budgets needed
for these costs or just delay the cost
by 30 to 90 days
um I think that that's a very good
question um and and you just have to
wonder what would happen to folks I
think one of the things that that's of
concern for the Commission on Aging is
that um um the challenge that many older
adults whether they have cognition um
there's an increased likelihood of of
cognition issues especially amongst um
homeless population and there b uh or
the or folks who have gone through a um
significant transition that might cause
them to go seek out welfare about their
ability to to gather the necessary uh
proof of residency that's named in this
bill additional
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you next the chair calls Mr Michael
branley followed by Mr Steven
Tower welcome to Municipal and County
Government good afternoon thank you my
name is Michael branley and I'm Town
Administrator for the town of Swansea
I'm here to speak in favor of the intent
behind this legislation the current
local welfare system is broken and local
officials local local welfare officials
are at their wits end because their
hands are tied by the welfare statutes
and the lack of Housing and other
resources New Hampshire needs real
welfare reform or for the state to take
on this obligation if the state is not
going to give municipalities the
resources or
flexibility um can pause for or answer
some of those questions that had come up
previously if it's helpful or just pause
for
questions is that is that your testimony
yes correct okay so perfect um
questions the chair recognizes
representative
grund thank you again Madam chair i'
would like to ask you the same question
do you think that this legislation would
reduce cost to towns or do you think it
would just delay the cost by 30 to or 90
days depending on what the amendment
says I I can't say for sure but I think
it would ensure that the towns that are
paying for the cost would be more likely
the place where the individual had
previously resided versus going to
another Community going from town to
town to hop for resources would be more
likely that that would they would be
receiving assistance from the community
uh where they had resided I think
overall Statewide it probably would end
up being similar but it would be shared
more or where the person had
resided further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony the chair calls Mr Steven
Tower and after that I will call Ms
Kristen Reynolds welcome to Municipal
and County government thank you good
morning uh for the sake of everyone's
lunch I'll try to be quick um so I'm
Steve Tower at New Hampshire Legal
Assistant
I am the director of our local welfare
project and have been since 2020 I work
very closely with local welfare
administrators across the state and the
local welfare administrators Association
on a variety of issues um and try to do
so in as collaboratively an approach as
possible um so this bill would change
the texts of RSA 165 colon one um
removing the line uh whether or not they
have residents there which some may be
thinking is a a strange line uh I
brought with me a copy of the New
Hampshire revised statutes from
1843 and uh back in 1843 the text of
this uh statute was word for word the
same except uh it it said whether or not
they have residence there is a current
language in 1843 it said whether or not
they had settlement in such Town
effectively the same language and that
language has been with us basically to
Colonial times it's been with us through
the Great Depression it's been through
the 60s and the 70s it was with us
through uh the Great Recession and it is
with us today and and there's a reason
for that which is RSA
165 um allows people to apply and access
assistance in the town that they are in
but does Define ultimate financial
responsibility the person who has to
foot the bill at the end of the day as
the place where they have residence
under the statute um and the reason for
that is to avoid someone being denied
assistance because of a dispute with a
town where a town says we don't we don't
believe that you have access to the
program under this statute you need to
go somewhere else and then they go to
that town and that town says no we don't
think you have residency here either and
so the person who is in generally
desperate need would get caught in this
pingpong situation between towns and the
statute is written such that when there
is a dispute like that between a town as
to where they think the person's true
residency lies um that can be resolved
through the towns under sections RSA 165
colon 19 and colon 20 or is it I believe
it's 20 and 20a um but uh so I I have
serious concerns about removing the the
the sentence in there about uh whether
or not they have residency would have a
detrimental impact on my clients but
more specifically the requirement for a
durational residency for the town that
is stated in the statute whether it is
90 days or 30 days uh imposes a
substantial problem if somebody were to
move and two and a two and a half months
later they are injured at work or are
fired or need heating oil in the winter
they would not be able to access local
welfare assistance in the town that they
have moved to like any other resident of
the town would nor as this is written
would they be able to get access under
local welfare from their prior residents
because they would not be able to
establish 90 days of continuous
residency in their prior residence
because they don't have residency any
there there anymore um so as written for
the time period stated in the statute a
person who has relocated either because
they have moved or because they have
became homeless and no longer have a
place that they could domicile in the
town that they resided and ended up in a
tent or in their car in another town
they would lose access to local welfare
anywhere in the state for the period of
time stated in the statute um my other
major and probably bigger concern about
the statute is as one of the the prior
Witnesses stated the new the US Supreme
Court has ruled several times that a
durational requirement for public
benefits is unconstitutional um the
first time was in
1969 uh there was a lot of litigation in
the 70s and 80s about well is there
wiggle room with the decision that the
Supreme Court came up with and
consistently every federal court case
that ruled on these durational
requirements struck them down um there
was again uh in the 90s where you may
remember there was a big welfare reform
bill that was passed during the Clinton
Administration Congress included in that
welfare reform Bill statements that
states could impose durational
requirements so Congress told states
that they could do this states started
doing it and those durational
requirements were struck down again and
the Supreme Court in 1999 specifically
said Congress can't authorize states to
violate the constitutional rights around
equal protection and the privileges and
immunities clause um so as this is
drafted the bill
would encourage or enable towns to uh
pass local welfare rules that would
violate the constitution so it is
unknowingly putting local welfare
officers in the situation where they may
taking the lead of this legislative body
enact one of these durational
requirements um and possibly end up in a
very
expensive federal civil rights
litigation case um and that's not good
for the town I do I like working with
the towns I like being able to work out
good Solutions with them them and I do
not want to see any Town end up in that
situation now there has been some
testimony here including from the prime
sponsor of concerns about towns paying
for costs that aren't fairly
attributable to the town and I do agree
that that is something that I'm very
concerned about because those costs
incurred by the town secondhand impact
my clients because towns are less
comfortable assisting people if they
feel like they're kind of getting the
short end of the stick from say another
town or something like that um so I'm
very interested in trying to find ways
to reduce those costs per towns but
unfortunately these residency
requirements that have a durational
element to it are not the way to do it
and I'm happy to work with the sponsor
and other parties to try to find ways to
cut the cost for towns thank you okay
thank you Mr Tower questions for the
speaker the chair recognizes
representative majority thank you madam
chairwoman and thank you for taking my
quick question if the residency
requirement was struck from this bill
would the bill be
okay um thank you for the question if
the
residency if the residency requirement
were struck from the
bill um I believe that is the the
majority of the bill there's there's
some other aspects of the bill that talk
about what documentation can be used for
establishing residency um but uh the the
changing RSA 165 to include a durational
residency requirement is the core of
this
bill further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you next the chair calls Ms Kristen
Reynolds followed by Mr Nick
Taylor welcome to Municipal and County
government hi Kristen Reynolds Swansea U
I'm here representing myself uh I moved
from Portland Oregon in
2022 and at that time the homeless
population was
incredible the entire downtown of
Portland was full of
tents in a very nice section of town
where we have this beautiful Park full
of
tents the mile in front of the river
full of
tents the rail trail that everybody like
to go on full of tents
this was a slow progression because the
west coast is known for being very very
generous and it was well known by
everybody that people were bust in they
would it was cheaper for places to just
give a bus ticket to somebody and then
send them to
us and we had an enormous population
explosion and as I said tents everywhere
that was three years ago my
understanding from my friends is that
they try to clear out the tents from
different areas and then those people go
to the smaller towns that are
nearby and put their tents up there
so I feel in some ways like I'm from the
future it doesn't look right now like
that could possibly happen but it didn't
look like it could possibly happen
10 years before I was in Portland you
know before I'm talking about because
when I moved to Portland it wasn't like
that at
all so that's all I wanted to say thank
you questions for the
speaker seeing none thank
you chair calls Mr Nick Taylor followed
by Miss Jennifer
Chisum thank you madam chair and members
of the committee I'm Nick Taylor I'm the
the director of housing action New
Hampshire we are an organization that
advocates for policies to increase
access to housing our members include
developers landlords lenders property
managers homeless service providers and
more we're here in opposition to this
bill as you know the committee knows New
Hampshire is facing a housing shortage
with record low vacancy rates record
high costs which is forcing more people
to become unhoused and out of their
homes uh as has been mentioned the
coalition to end homelessness is report
found that there's been over 50%
increase in homelessness from 2022 to
2023 and anecdotally we're hearing the
same thing from our members where they
are at capacity and having to in some
cases turn folks away and doing the very
best they can to serve uh their
communities and the people in New
Hampshire we appreciate the intent you
know behind trying to reduce the burden
on local welfare departments we fully
support that and support the efforts to
reduce homelessness and and that
functionally on that in New Hampshire
but this bill wouldn't do that it would
either delay as been mentioned when the
costs get incurred and over those first
time period it will still be a cost and
still be in need and so it will either
get picked up by the soup kitchens and
the faith-based organizations and the
shelter providers that don't have wiggle
room to take in any more folks or take
in any more resources or it will be
picked up by Municipal law enforcement
and EMS and fire departments who are
called when emergencies strike because
people aren't accessing the funds or are
out on the streets so this is just
shifting around the cost and will have
immense damage we believe in terms of
the severity and frequency of of
homelessness and being able to uh
support the folks that need the help so
we oppose this bill happy to take any
questions questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you for your
testimony do you have something written
uh it's got notes all over it but I will
email it to the committee thank
you the chair calls Miss Jennifer Chisum
followed by Miss Judith Jones jokie
Benny welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you madam chairperson
um and the rest of the committee uh so
my name is Jennifer Chisum and I am the
executive director of the New Hampshire
coalition to end
homelessness oh is that
okay um so I am Jennifer Chism and I'm
the executive director of the New
Hampshire coalition to end homelessness
um and we oppose this bill um and so I
will be short uh people have already
discussed some of the things that you'll
find in my written testimony that I just
submitted um
but homelessness continues to be a
critical and growing issue in the state
of New Hampshire so as was discussed um
the the numbers uh from the point in
time count which is that time in January
the 24-hour period where we try and
estimate the number of people
experiencing homelessness um is really
spiking interestingly today is actually
the 2025 count so if I seem a little
blur eyed um I've been up since 3:30
because I help with the Manchester count
this morning um but some additional pick
count data for you they talked about
people have talked about the 52%
increase that we were the highest
increase in the United States between
2022 and
2023 um and since 2019 chronic or
long-term homelessness in New Hampshire
has increased uh by over 50% and
extremely concerningly the number of New
Hampshire residents experiencing
unsheltered homelessness and so living
in a tent during their car for example
has nearly quadrupled um between 2019
and
2024 uh but amid these spikes the
passage of HB 348 would make it
virtually impossible for those who are
chronically homeless or living
unsheltered to access local welfare and
so it would create this waiting period
for accessing welfare support that could
literally mean the difference between
life and death when it comes to basic
needs needs that affect a person's safe
safety and health so for example many
areas of the state local Welfare Offices
play a extremely vital role in helping
people access Emergency Shelters and
warming centers in frigid weather um so
I don't know where you're all from but
the other morning it was1 in Manchester
um when I woke up so um some
municipalities are over an hour away uh
from their nearest emergency shelter
with no public transportation available
to our residents and so in these cases
the local welfare office can pay for
Trans Transportation cost to the shelter
in the unlikely chance that there's
actually a bed available um or provide a
local Motel voucher as a fatality
prevention measure um and so in these
situations people can't wait 90 days it
is an immediate need um so it may sound
overly dramatic but the reality truly is
that denying timely access to local
welfare support could cost residents
lives um prior to being with the
Coalition I was a social worker um in
Manchester for about 20 years um
including 10 years with the healthcare
for the homeless program doing direct
social work um in on the streets and in
the encampments and so I can speak from
lived experience working directly with
people that this is this is the truth um
deest domestic violence was also
mentioned um you know having somebody
come in and local welfare truly being
the last resort um of a a social worker
who has sat down for an entire day
calling domestic violence shelters that
do not have availability for people and
local welfare pulling through and being
able to put that person in a Hotel say
overnight um to provide me more time to
be able to to case manage that person
and help make those connections um
because it you know we do help people
get connected with those other services
and somebody referred to um other
service um other services is cumbersome
and it sort of made me smile because
oftentimes when talking with clients in
the past about applying for local local
welfare um they have said I'm not I'm
not doing that application um you know
and so um that made me laugh and then
somebody else also uh mentioned
medication support so being able to
provide us time to get somebody life a
life um a necessary prescription while
as a case manager I work with somebody
to get them connected with Medicaid um
which is not a quick process so again
sometimes the idea of waiting 90 days is
just unfathomable
unfathomable
um and I think that that's where I'll
leave it so thank you so much for your
time and your consideration thank you
questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
you next the chair calls Miss Judith
Jones jokie Benny followed by Mr Todd
Marsh you're
together
okay then that would be fine um welcome
to Municipal and County government so
both both just please state your name
and where you're from your position for
the record thank you
[Music]
sorry my name is Judith Jones and I'm
also at from new
Futures many of you may be aware new
Futures and as I said as a nonpartisan
nonprofit Health policy and advocacy
organization in addition to our work
around substance use and Healthcare
access we are New Hampshire's designated
kids count organization and we lead the
policy work for the New Hampshire
Alliance for healthy aging a Statewide
Coalition uh focused on the health and
wellbeing of older adults in our state
all is to say at new Futures we advocate
for health all across the lifetime and
we are here to oppose this bill as it
threatens the health of the health and
well-being of all the age sets we aim to
serve Judith is going to talk for a
moment about the impacts of of of local
assistance and and this bill on on Aging
adults uh but suffice it to say all all
across the life span people depend on
local welfare to support their most
basic needs when they're at their most
vulnerable this is a Lifeline for people
who have lost their jobs lost their
homes when they have had a major medical
event or as my colleague Miss Stevens
mentioned when they are coming out of
treatment for mental illness or
substance use disorder often times these
disruptive events force people to need
to relocate move in with family members
or move to another Community for uh to
seek Supportive Housing uh so to require
90 days residency or as any residency
require as proposed in this bill would
effectively deny many individuals as
critical assistance exactly when they
need it most uh suffice it to say when
individuals again those coming out of of
mental health or substance use treatment
are not able to access local welfare it
impacts their access how they're able to
access their their medication how
they're able to access uh health care
services and where and and certainly
impacts their housing stability of
course this increases the chance the
likelihood of of relapse or recurrence
uh of their their substance use disorder
or their mental illness which is
obviously something we as a state have
worked uh so hard to combat uh in
addition to the impact of those
individuals you have to look at the
impacts on families and young children
uh increasing uh uh few food insecurity
or housing instability among younger
children exposes them to toxic stress or
adverse childhood experiences which of
course impacts their development
throughout their lives uh and with that
I'll leave it to Judith to talk about
adults thank you so much for your time
I'm not going to repeat some of the
statistics that you've heard about the
Aging population just um what you have
heard is the a the population of New
Hampshire of Aging adults is increasing
poverty in New Hampshire among aging
adults is increasing and now we have the
rate of homelessness among older
individuals increasing we used to see
just these as National Trends and now
we're calling them home to New Hampshire
local welfare is a critical safety net
and as many speakers have talked about
it comes at a key time I one example say
someone who's had housing consist
consistently for 20 years an older adult
on a fixed income rent goes
up twice unable to maintain that housing
and if you you've heard from testimony
with other committees the the short the
shortage of the housing so someone who's
lost their housing an older adult has to
move in with a family member under this
bill if my family is taking care of me
but I have an urgent need for medication
I have no longer any lease proof of live
that this person's needs would not be
able to be met under this
bill older adults often are on fixed
incomes and what that means is often a
household household of two a married
couple can afford the cost of living in
New Hampshire but what we find is once a
spouse dies you're trying to maintain a
household on a social security check
the average social security check of
January n January
2025 is $1900 a month in the written
material you'll find a link to something
called elder index and it will tell you
the cost of living for older adults in
each county in the United States so you
can look up chesher you can look up
Hillsboro you can look up Rockingham and
the cost of living over
$2,800 chesher in the $3,000 Hills B in
the
$3,000 Rockingham just knowing this is
what the older population is facing we
thank local Weare for their availability
and say this is an urgent
need thank you for your testimony and I
apologize um on the pink card I thought
you were one person with four four names
and I want to apologize publicly for the
record that my handwriting will get
better and I thought I was doing good
with my deciphering of handwriting and
pronunciation
you questions for the
speakers seeing none thank
you hey we're done we're down to two
cards the chair calls Mr Todd Marsh
followed by Mr Freeman
Toth good afternoon uh it's nice to see
so many familiar faces in front of me
and behind me um yes my name is Todd
Marsh and I am here representing the New
Hampshire local welfare administrators
Association um I am also the welfare
director uh for the great City of
Rochester um 21 years uh prior to my
employment with Rochester I was director
of the homeless Center for traffic
County uh and I was also res residential
manager at the My Friends Place shelter
uh in Dober um as representative Walker
knows I do enjoy talking about local
welfare um so I will do my best to stick
to my notes and then uh answer questions
that you may have um the New Hampshire
local welfare administrators Association
is a professional nonprofit organization
that educates and supports our Municipal
members to Foster compliant humanitarian
and fiscally responsible assistance
practices when assisting
residents with our statutorily obligated
needs Municipal welfare is a valuable
expert Human Service voice and advisory
resource to decision makers within town
and City Halls throughout New
Hampshire um our association opposes the
bill as initially
written uh since our association learned
about this bill about two week and a
half two weeks ago um I have been in
communication with representative
RADS um and it that has been much
appreciated um also we also appreciate
her sensitivity to
taxpayers um I have been in
communication with legal aid with NH HMA
we we all met um in a room prior to the
session holding hands maybe not holding
hands but you know we we discussed the
bill um and uh that was of value uh due
to our collaboration the language has
been in flux uh including up to as I
said about an hour ago um we agree our
association agrees that continuous
Improvement is important including
during Changing Times um and we welcome
discussions we believe the initial uh
unamended Bill uh to have been
unworkable with too many unintended
consequences including the 90 days for
residency criteria and it was brought up
earlier and that was a excellent example
someone from Rochester could potentially
voluntarily with no assistance move to
conquered two and a half months later
potentially need oil and they would
potentially go back to the city of
Rochester um for it so these logistic um
uh challenges would exist and I and I do
believe that they were unintended by the
way uh the consensus of our board uh and
I should say that I have um gauged many
welfare officials throughout the state
since I've learned of this uh including
our board of directors the consensus is
one
day the current law one day perhaps Too
Short however 90 days is too long again
unworkable to navigate and with harm and
with likely harm um 30 days with was the
consensus um but with Safeguard language
to temporarily assist people with an
urgent emergency need regardless of town
of origin until the welfare official can
communicate and coordinate with other
municipalities and that language was put
in the word was sh in the S sp10 and I
will say and I've talked to welfare
officials throughout the state that law
has been very beneficial um the focus
was um homeless shelters correction
facilities hospitals uh that they do not
con they no longer constitute residency
for local welfare purposes that just
simply made sense this bill here is much
broader um again with some concerning um
um sections to it um I will also say
that um the vast majority of the folks
that approach us are solidly solidly um
residents of our municipalities most of
them are not folks that are Here There
and Everywhere they're they're solid
Rochester they're solid other
municipalities um however it does exist
um where people may approach us late in
the day on a Friday that are from
somewhere else it does happen um the the
um the temporary assistance langage Mr
Marsh um you you now four four minutes
but I am closing do you and do you have
written testimony I can get that to you
I am one more par short paragraph Yes um
what I just indicated regarding
temporary assistance is actually in
current law for non-residents that was
in s
sp110 um I will move forward and state
that um where is that balance where is
the balance the one versus 90 again 30
uh we believe that we're almost there
and we believe that an additional work
session could be of value here um to
worksmith some of those words and the
intent um because there can be value in
in Improvement um but we do not believe
that we're there thank you thank you Mr
Marsh also um your pink card you um
omitted your disposition on the bill
could you mark that initial it yes um we
I omitted it I omitted it because I was
unsure um of the Amendments that were
going to be introduced but we do oppose
under the for the current initial
language I can admin that thank you
questions for Mr
Marsh the chair recognizes
representative majori thank you mad
chair we I'll make it quick do in your
conversations um do you believe we'll
see something that strikes The Residency
requirement and creates a that is
workable or will it include the
residency
requirement I hope that in our
conversations I I hope that the final
bill that's with amendments that's
brought to you I hope that it is one of
if it is 30 days um that for our
association to um support it it would
need to have that Safeguard language uh
of temporary assisting people uh that uh
are in front of us at that moment until
we can coordinate them um um um um to
their town of
origin further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you and the last pink card that I have
is Mr Freeman Toth welcome to Municipal
and County
government so I I see that you have
asked for five minutes could you yeah I
can condense I'll keep this brief
and you also um I don't know if it was
intentional but
didn't um indicate your position if you
want would you like to amend that was
that an oversight I no it was not an
oversight um because I'm a nonpartisan
organization um uh I work for Community
Action Program of belnap and maram
counties um understood okay so I'm I'm
just here to speak to unintended
consequences of these actions um so my
name is Freeman to I manage the homeless
Outreach and housing stability
department for the belnap Marat
Community Action Program I oversee for
the two counties the state housing
stabilization homeless prevention fund
um and uh today is the national HUD
point in time homeless persons count
it's like a census for those
experiencing homelessness and I uh I
apologize uh for my appearance uh but
I've been outside in the woods working
with people who are
suffering um local control is not
working many other states at this uh at
this point uh have handed this over to
the county
um I have many elderly uh participants
families uh living in their vehicles uh
because local welfare and other homeless
prevention uh mechanisms are uh have
have failed uh and we do not have enough
shelter per capita um the 90-day element
uh will exclude many of our most
vulnerable community members I'm talking
about your grandmothers um and uh
children
um domestic violence shelters and cold
weather shelters respectfully are full
they do the best they can with uh the
resources they have um and many of those
I work with are literally excluded from
accessing the shelters due to screening
questions like can you reach a top bunk
I can tell you right now if you answer
no to that question when being screened
you will not get a bed
um and that's if shelter is available
the conquered cold weather shelter to my
knowledge I work closely with their team
has been full um the Isaiah 60 Cafe
Isaiah 61 Cafe in my catchment which is
a cold weather shelter is almost always
full um or close to it if they have more
than three to five beds it's unusual um
homeless prevention funds like these
that I oversee are over taxed and
underresourced is my calendar year for
my homeless prevention program runs from
July 1st to June 30th last year so My my
year will end this June 30th of 2025 I
ran out of money to prevent homelessness
because of the need right now um in
October of last year okay and uh and
we're not getting any additional funds
so right now local welfare is the safety
net people are dying because I have no
place to put them
I understand as a taxpayer I've owned a
home in Manchester since 2003 and have
been a lifelong resident of New
Hampshire I was also a homeless college
student at
19 we can do a lot better than we're
doing changing these laws to make things
more restrictive and give people more
reasons to look for an answer to say no
is not the answer we need to be looking
for reasons to say yes help should be
easy to get and hard to keep um so I
fully support everything was just saying
I work closely with his his team um and
I'd just like to answer any questions
that any of you might have at this point
thank you for your time thank you Mr to
questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you thank you
for your
time so I just had a an additional pink
card
manifest and that um at this time I will
call
Representative Steve
bogur welcome to Municipal and County
government first of all I'd like to uh
introduce myself I'm Steph Bogard I'm a
state rep for belnap County District 5
I'm also the city counselor in
lonia uh for Ward five so I kind of see
this Prospect from many different
angles uh in uh lonia Laconia is the
uh forgot the word but it's the central
town for bellnap County so you have all
the services that come to our uh that
are available you have the Lakes Region
Mental Health Organization you have an
office of cap that comes up you have uh
we have three
to uh homeless shelters that work within
this organization we have a uh a house
for uh ladies who have had violence
against them and are other uh medical
issues we have that available within our
town uh now we've also had a large
transient population that has uh over
the last three years in flowed and
within that if you looked at the budget
for the City of
Laconia uh three or year three years ago
maybe four it was a
$40,000 line item in the budget and it
was pretty stable throughout all the
years and then we started seeing it
creep it creeped up this past year it's
approaching
$200,000 and it's going to be for the
proposed budget I'm suspecting to see it
well over
$200,000 to provide the services that
are being
suggested uh by the current language in
the bill this the cities have no
resource other than to pass this on to
the property tax
owners now a lot of people are sitting
here talking about
housing and people are being pushed out
of their housing because of rent
increases one must ask themselves what
is a primary cause of house increase or
the rent
increase I'll I'll help answer that that
is called increase in your property tax
now what's going to go to help increase
your property tax is your welfare line
so every time you've got a a group of
folks who are living on the
edge okay and what happens is you're
going to raise the property the the
property tax and as property tax raises
the owner of that property is not going
to eat it because they still have to
make their margin because that's what
they're in business for so they pass on
that
increase to the renters of that building
now you you're going to have people who
could afford it yesterday could afford
to pay for it just barely now they've
been pushed off the edge so
we yes we have increased
homelessness by trying to fix problems
every time we try to fix a problem and
pass it on to the local municipalities
to fix it then that increases the
property tax ta so if we really want to
feel good about
ourselves then maybe the state should
take on the responsibility of paying for
this kind of welfare that they want to
offer the original welfare wasn't set up
to help transits as they move in and out
of cities and take advantage of the
different situations in welfare for each
Town it was set up to help their locals
as a family fell on Hard Times the town
could come in and they could help them
get across the hump get across that bump
that's what a lot of people need is
shortterm help to get across the bridge
but what happens is with the transi
population representative bogur you may
not have been in the room when when I
announced we were setting three 3
minutes would you be able to um wrap up
your testimony yes and if needed you can
provide something to the committee thank
you yes I think everybody understands
the direction that was coming that
there's more in depth than just this
side to it so I'm open to questions if
anybody has them thank you
representative questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you thank
you at this time that was my final pink
card um I'd like to ask if there is
anyone present in the room who wishes to
speak to this bill who has not yet had
the opportunity to do
so seeing no one we will report out on
the blue sheet thank you madam chair uh
today's blue sheet had two uh votes in
support and five in opposition and one
neutral the remote sign in had2 in
support I'm sorry
112 opposing the bill and uh nine in
support thank you representative Gilman
with that I will close the public
hearing on House Bill
348 so committee members it is now
approximately quarter to 1 according to
our publicly noticed business for today
we are to um take up two additional
bills beginning at
1:00 so I will what we're going to do is
going to take a break we're going to be
back here at 1 and follow the plan that
I um stated
before when we finish these two bills
then we will
take um a nice lunch break and then come
back and exec thank
you
e
e e
okay welcome everybody so the time now
is 1:00 p.m. and we are scheduled to
resume our public hearings and the we
are on time so the the first bill we
have scheduled here is for 1 p.m. so at
this time I will open the public hearing
on House Bill 4 53 prohibiting
municipalities from Banning use of
ground Grounds Maintenance and snow and
ice remove removal equipment with
internal combustion
engines so
um I would like that the prime sponsor
has properly notified me and
unfortunately he is unable to be here
today so representative stavis has um
graci graciously AG aged to introduce
the bill to our committee on behalf of
the
sponsor good afternoon rep
representative stavis good afternoon
chair power and members of the municipal
and County government committee my name
is Laurel stavis I represent the city of
Lebanon uh Grafton
13 and I uh have no opinion on this bill
uh I am here to introduce House Bill
453 which prohibits municipalities from
Banning the use of Grounds Maintenance
and snow and ice removal equipment with
internal combustion
engines and that concludes my
introduction of the
Bill thank you you representative stavis
do we have pink cards for this
bill okay um so I will ask is there
anyone here present that wishes to
testify on this bill who has not yet had
the opportunity to do so and seeing none
I will now close the public hearing on
House Bill
453 oh I'm sorry excuse me
I I forgot the the the blue
sheet U Madam chair there uh the remote
testimony in support five opposed
five and one one
opposed on the blue
sheet thank you representative Gilman
that went very fast
so the next bill that we have publicly
noticed is House Bill 488 and that
begins at
1:20 so we have a few minutes to wait
okay
yeah it's you
know no
was
e
e e
good afternoon the time is 1:20 and we
are scheduled to hear House Bill
488 at this time I will open the public
hearing on House Bill 488 relative to
limiting conflicts of interest for mun
ipal boards and committee
members now the prime sponsor has um
properly noticed me that he is unable to
be here today to introduce the bill so
representative frock has
graciously volunteered to do that on the
prime sponsor's behalf
thank you madam chair members of the
committee I'm David
fra representing Grafton 16 the town of
Enfield I have been asked to
introduce House Bill
488 relative to limiting conflicts of
interest for municipal board and
committee members this is a
[Music]
rewrite
of
RSA
669 colon
7 and I'm sure everybody has had an
opportunity to read through it during
the break and knows exactly what the
differences between the two versions
are are there any
questions questions for representative
frock
seeing Oh representative Dolan thank you
madam chair is can you speak to the
differences between this bill and HB 92
which we're going to be executing later
this
afternoon
um I can tell you that HB
92 deals specifically with conflict of
interest or conflicts between uh person
sitting on a planning board and a zoning
board um this
669 or
HB what is it
488 um does not address that particular
conflict but is a broader stroke um
encompassing more boards and Municipal
Employees and potential conflicts there
thank
you additional questions representative
Elward thank you Madame chairman and
thank you representative
frock um would you say there's a
difference between a municipal board and
a land use
board they are both Municipal
boards um a land use board has a
specific function it deals with land
use um another board board um I can't
think of a name uh but the name would
reflect the purpose of the
board the chair recognizes
representative Murphy for a question
thank you madam chair is there a
possibility write an amendment to put HB
92 into HB
448 um that would certainly be Poss
possible but not
advisable and the reason it would not be
advisable is because it's in a
completely different section of the
rsas uh HB 92 deals specifically with
powers of planning boards and zoning
boards and that's found in 673 and
674 and the reason that the amendment is
being proposed is to make 100% certain
that people who are on those boards
understand the need to um recuse
themselves and not have a a
conflict thank you you're further
questions no seeing none thank you for
your excellent Bill introduction thank
you madam
chair also um I would ask that you fill
out a pink card
next the chair recognizes representative
Heath Howard to speak on the bill
welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you madam chair and
thank you honorable committee members uh
my name is representative Heath Howard I
represent the towns of straford and
barington in straford District 4 uh I'm
appearing in front of you today because
I am opposed to hb4 as it is currently
ridden because of the effect that the
legislation will have on my town uh the
town of straford has one person serving
in uh the positions of both Town Clerk
and tax collector it is our belief that
this could pose an issue as finding
qualified people who are willing and
able to serve in both positions can be
difficult uh after having a uh an email
conversation with both representative
spillsbury and our uh town clerk uh and
tax collector uh there was kind of a
suggestion proposed in my opinion it
would be far less honorous and would
allow still allow for the goal of the
legislation to be accomplished if an
amendment to remove the term if
authorized as provided in RSA 41
45- from page one line 8 is uh is
removed uh with that being said uh I'm
open to any questions thank
you the chair recognizes representative
Guthrie for a question
thank you madam
chair in in the bill and thank you for
taking my question in the bill under C
says no full-time employee or department
head shall at the same time hold the
office of
selectman uh I can see some maybe minor
problems with the department head but
could you tell me why a full-time
employee of a town maybe somebody who's
working for the Board of Public Works uh
you know a maintenance person would not
be able to have a selectman if he could
get elected uh that that's not what I'm
in opposition to uh specifically I'm in
opposition to uh Part B so that would be
uh uh part I section B no Town Clerk or
Deputy town clerk May hold any other
elected appointed or appointed office
other than tax collector if authorized
as provided in RSA
4145 or Deputy tax
collector uh and so after my
conversation with representative
spillsbury uh through via email it was
suggested that uh if we struck the the
term if authorized as provided in RSA 41
45- A that would be uh beneficial
because uh right now 41 uh 45 UHA what
that does is it requires approval uh by
the town in the form of a vote so uh in
in terms of the town of straford we have
a town meeting day so we would have to
hold a vote uh every time to uh to
reaffirm that our town clerk uh can be
our our um our tax collector as well
thank thank you for your information
yeah if I may Madam chair probably asked
the question by somebody who has an
interest in another part of this Bill
thank you yes thank you I'll oh are you
asking for a followup
no Madam chair I'm
asking uh just commenting that I will
ask that question to maybe some other
party who testifies understood thank you
all right thank you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you next the chair recognizes Miss Joan
Dary
welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you
sorry um my name is Joan dargy and I'm
um the president of the Hampshire City
and town clerks Association and I'm here
to represent them in opposition to this
bill um trying to fix a problem for one
town with a oneforall solution at times
does not necessarily work our
association requested our legal
counsel um Attorney courtel Johnson to
review HB 488 and with your permission
I'd like to to read the response and I
also have copies for
everybody
if um I would I would you could speak to
the ideas okay that's I want you to
provide um testimony but you can
certainly
so he um so we're primarily focusing on
the prohibition in lines 7 through eight
of the bill no Town Clerk or Deputy town
clerk May hold any other elected or
appointed office other than tax
collector if authorized as provided in
RSA 41 colon
45- or Deputy tax collector it is
unclear why the bill singles out clerks
and deputies no other person is
subjected to this blanket Prohibition in
small New Hampshire towns there simply
are non people to serve in local
government this bill makes the problem
worse in one town that is um rep one in
one town the town clerk is the fire
chief they would no longer be able to do
that in another town the town clerk is
the Town Administrator that would no
longer be allowed so we're we're talking
and that's just two examples of um many
others that are out there where this
would create a hardship for those for
those towns
um one very strange uh result of this
bill is that ital it this would prohibit
a town clerk from also serving as a
school clerk we have
multiple uh situations where that I
myself I was the Town Clerk and the
school clerk for years I'm not presently
but I have been um and because we do
similar jobs the school Clerk and town
clerk it makes sense for for the town
clerk to be able to also Ser as school
clerk um there is an RSA 31 colon
39a um that the town meeting May adopt
an ordinance establishing
incompatibility of office requirements
stricter than those specified by the law
towns can already do that and I've also
supplied a copy so towns can can go to
town meeting and they can make stricter
laws than what exist in
669 um colon
7 and finally um it is the um legal
council's
um opinion that this bill May violate
part one article 11 of the New Hampshire
Constitution which states in part every
inhabitant of the state having the
proper qualifications has equal right to
be elected into office presumably some
reasonable limitations on this right are
acceptable such as the prohibition to
discussed above on a Town employee
serving as selectman or the prohibition
on serving as both selectman and
moderator however HB 488 would Pro
prohibit a town clerk or Deputy clerk
from holding any other elected office
except for tax collector this broad
prohibition may very well violate the
constitution and um with that I'm open
to any questions anybody might
have thank you questions for Miss Dary
seeing none and may I submit this I also
have a letter from the Woodstock select
board so what is it that you're
submitting um a letter from the
Woodstock select board and then the um
our um the attorney's our New Hampshire
City and town clerk's legal council's
opinion on
488 could you just hold for one second
sure
we're checking on something so um just
if you might not if you would like to
hold that's fine um this Bill had come
up last year and um and the basically
the same letter had been submitted to
the senent it at the
time understood
so while I'm waiting for an answer from
the house
clerk we I'll direct you as to to to
what you need to do with regards to what
you have in your hand okay so that it's
the last pink card that I have so I will
ask is there anyone present who wishes
to speak on this bill who has not yet
had the opportunity to do
so okay seeing seeing none we will
report out the blue sheet at this
time uh Madam chair I have nothing from
any handwritten blue sheet I remotely
there is one in support and 26 in
opposition
okay let me correct that we had three
three in opposition on the blue sheet
today thank you representative Gilman
Miss Dari do do you have written
testimony of your
own okay that's
fine no you don't need to
um why don't you just put put the the
testimony as communication to the
committee right there or at the end of
the table yep and then we will um sort
that
out okay so at this time I will be
closing the public hearing on House Bill
okay so as we had discussed earlier I
had um talked to the ranking member at
this point in time we will take a a
one-hour lunch break does that sound
reasonable and we will come back here at
one at
2:40 at which time we will begin the
executive
session thank
you
e
e e
good afternoon welcome or welcome back
to Municipal and County Government at
this point in time the committee will um
commence an executive session to exec
seven bills that we heard last week so
the purpose of an executive session is
for the committee to consider each bill
and to vote to make a committee
recommendation which will go to the
house floor for a vote at a future
date scheduled house session
so I'd like to um point out to committee
members that there are a number of
amendments that may be
offered um to several
bills I have counted one two three six
amendments that you should have at your
desks if you don't have those just raise
your hand and we'll sort you out you
have
five okay so um you should have
Amendment
6h to House Bill
86 then there is also an amendment 20250
049 to House Bill
okay
62 all right am I not
looking all
right so representative
all right
frocked what is the amendment to 92 I
may
have
okay I have
um obsolete number
here then to House Bill 99 you should
have Amendment
45h does everybody have that
okay everybody all
set then to House Bill 110 we have um
two potential amendments ending in 57h
and
58h I
only I don't I don't have a five I have
five
hey
so I have um
57h to House Bill 110 coming around the
table
from both
ends
okay take two one one B file and one for
you you have
two have two 57s I
leave we could sort that out later and
then lastly everybody should have an
amendment to House Bill 78 ending in
34h 34h yeah I just didn't want to say
the whole
number okay
34 I have two
di you stole it I
did so is everybody um set with
amendments everybody
good so the chair will have homework to
figure out a better method for getting
the Amendments at your
desks
okay so you're all set
right yeah
okay
right at this time I will open the
executive session on House Bill
84 allowing Miss municipalities to
collect fees for certain recreational
vehicles located on Campground property
ities the chair would like to recognize
representative McDonald for a
motion thank you uh Mr chairman I'd like
to recommend
itl is there a
second I'll second that Madam chairwoman
thank you representative maiori seconds
that
discussion the chair recognizes repres
representative maiori thank you
chairwoman you know I think we kind of
get
it we have an issue here but there are
mechanisms in place as a matter of fact
RSA
82 says that it's a misdemeanor real
estate mov and a tax bill has not been
paid there are mechanisms where these
folks U where that money can be recouped
but even more than that what this build
sets up is a situation where a
campground owner becomes a tax collector
and even if that were practical there's
no mechanism for the collection or for
the uh for the for for Distributing that
money back to the town so given that
there is a way for the municipality to
recoup and there is no clearly defined
way practical way for the owner to to to
effectuate this bill uh I I don't think
that this is practical and support the
itl maret thank you I didn't turn my mic
on sorry want me to repeat
that that's okay um the chair rep the
chair recog izes representative
Walker yes uh thank you madam chair uh I
think 84 would solve a lot of lot of
problems that are going along with RVs
and municipalities especially like in
Rochester and the $200 fee in place of
real estate tax would probably be a
great idea but there's just too many
holes elsewhere that things can fall
through or not get done so I'm in
support of itl
further comments or
discussion seeing none the motion before
us is inexpedient to legislate itl on
House Bill 84 the clerk will call the
role
Vice chair McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative L Elward
yes the clerk says
yes representative France
yes representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative magor
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana yes
representative Gerard
yes representative grund
yes
oh chairman
McDonald excuse me nervous chairman
power
yes sorry about that
the vote is 18 to Zer the committee
recommendation on House Bill 84 is
inexpedient to legislate without
objection the recommendation will go on
to the consent
calendar seeing
none the committee report will be
authored by representative McDonald
at this time I will close the executive
session on House Bill
84 e
we're just allowing the clerk to catch
up on the required
paperwork at this time I will open the
executive session on House Bill 86
increasing the cost of service for
notice of civil forfeiture of unlicensed
dogs to the rate for certified male
the chair would like to recognize
representative
Murphy thank you madam chair I have an
amendment here that the that the US
Postal Service rate of certified mail
with return receipt at the time of the
mailing the same cost for the service
the US Post Office rate of a certified
mail with the return receipt shall apply
for delivery of such notice in hand or
left at the Abode of the dog owner owner
the cost of the service in any
case this will eliminate having to
revisit this in about 5 years when the
postal rates go up and a lot of towns
aren't even uh doing it because of the
cost
second just wait
so representative Walker seconds the
acceptance of the
amendment is there any
discussion
comments okay seeing none we will put
acceptance of amendment number
0036 H to House Bill 86 to a vote so if
you are in favor of accepting
the amendment you will vote Yes if you
are opposed to accepting this amendment
you will vote
no the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative
Alward
yes the the clerk says
yes representative
France representative Kinski
yes representative Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative magor
yes representative frock
yes representative Co
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard yes
representative grund
yes chairman power
yes it's
18 so the vote on amendment number
202536 to House Bill
86 is 18 to Z and the amendment is
accepted the chair at this point would
like to recognize representative Murphy
for a
motion I like to make a motion do they
have passes pass this as
amended pass House Bill uh 86 as amended
so the motion that is being offered is
ought to pass as amendment is there a
second second representative Walker
seconds that motion
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call the
role Vice chair
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan
yes representative
Elward
yes the clerk says yes
representative France
yes representative Kosinski yes
representative
Murphy
yes representative Walker
yes representative stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative magor
yes representative frock
yes representative Colby yes
representative gerana yes representative
Gerard
yes representative grund
yes chairman
power
yes
180 the vote on the motion ought to pass
as amended on House Bill 86 is 18
to0 the um committee recommendation is
uh to pass as Amendment
amended that will go onto the consent
calendar without
objection seeing none and the committee
report will be authored by
representative
Murphy Madam chair when is this
do it's it's due with within 48 Hours
unless there's an issue just contact me
thank
you with that I will close the executive
session on House Bill
86 e
next I will open the executive session
on House Bill 92 prohibiting an
individual from simultaneously serving
on the local zoning board and planning
board the chair recognizes
representative
FR
no thank you madam
chair um my name is David
fra and in my spare time I chair the
planning board in the town of Enfield so
I have a little bit of familiarity with
the
subject um the original bill as
presented proposes to excuse me
representative frock um could you offer
I I think you want to offer an amendment
is that correct yes very good Could you
um State as such and please State the
amendment number and then you can we
need a second and then if you get a
second then you you you can speak to to
your Amendment thank you I apologize no
problem um I would like to offer
amendment number
[Music]
202562 which is an amendment to HB
92 thank you is there a
second representative Gilman seconds
that representative frock would you like
to speak to your amendment I would thank
you madam chair very good um as I said
in my spare time I chair the planning
board in my town which is Enfield and
I've done so for
probably six or seven years um the bill
as
introduced wants to prohibit an
individual from serving on both a
planning board and a zoning board and
and the reason for that is there can be
occasions when a member is uh sitting on
both boards would be making a decision
on or ruling on an appeal to a decision
that he or she has already made as a
member of a planning board for those of
you who are not familiar with the land
use
process uh um if an applicant wants to
do a project he may start out with the
zoning board seeking a variance or a
special exception the applicant then may
go to the planning board if it's a
commercial uh situation or a subdivision
the planning board may send him back to
the zoning board for yet another um
zoning variance or special
exception uh then might go back to the
planning board and it can bounce back
and
forth uh the final decision of the
planning board can then be appealed to
the zoning board and when that happens
we feel it's a conflict of interest for
an individual to be taking part in an
appeal
decision that he was initially part of
making so what we propose and by we uh
this is a
bipartisan uh Amendment representative
Elward and I work together to draft
this and what we propose is in when such
a situation arises the individual recuse
himself from the zoning board when they
have their deliberations on the appeal
and that solves the problem it allows
a person to sit on both boards in a town
where it may be difficult to find enough
people to fill all of the available
slots and we think it's a a very good
Amendment um and will help the process
of developing or not developing as the
case may be certain properties in the
state
Madame chair would you recognize uh B
Elward please yes thank you
representative frock for that
explanation um comments discussion the
chair recognizes representative
Elward thank you Madame
chairman um representative frock and I
worked on this amendment and I think
it's his first amendment my my
second um
unfortunately crawling up and over the
learning
curve we didn't uh run this by the New
Hampshire Municipal Association who
pointed
out um elements of the amended language
that is is not not ready for prime time
and so I cannot support this amendment
in its current um um
condition
um basically it conflicts with uh other
types of local land use boards such as
the
um what are those commissions that are
defined in
statute and so the the the wording local
land use boards in the amended
language
um needs to be specified as a zba and
the planning board uh to make it work so
I I will not be supporting um
otpa further comments representative
Walker yeah I've uh spent uh 15 years on
this Rochester's planning board and it
was always been a no no for someone to
serve on the planning board and the
zoning board for the reasons being
discussed and just because recuses or
that person recuses themselves they're
still on the board and can sway votes
and it's very not a good optic for the
people that come in and get say denied
for variance or a uh a a plan and then
go to the appeal to the zoning board and
the same guy that denied you sitting on
that board not maybe not voting but
sitting just bad Optics and we've always
had a rule that no one can serve on both
those boards in Rochester anyway
thank you
ma'am additional
comments repres oh representative
Elward just for clarification
representative Walker um we were
responding to concerns I think brought
by representative Gilman that many of
the some of these very small towns um
can't populate their boards and
sometimes have to put
people on on
both just to let you
know thank you further comments the
chair recognizes representative majori
thank you madam chairwoman
um I I'm I'm a co-sponsor on the on the
underlying bill so the the overarching
principle I I certainly support I I I
question though the language that OS has
has given us here it says the individual
shall recuse him or herself from voting
on matters pre viously decided on by
another
board on which he or she is an alternate
member and I wonder I'm on the Heritage
commission which has demo review and
while the Heritage commission is
advisory I'm the select board
representative to the planning board
which means that would I have to recuse
myself from a vote on the planning board
because I'm on the Heritage commission
and while we might not have an answer to
that I think the language that has been
presented it to us makes me question
whether or not I'm right or if that may
if that may exist so I still like the
idea I just don't know that this
language gets us where we need to
be no disrespect I think this is the
language they gave us so sorry further
comments representative
Elward uh responding to representative
majority I I think you're right and
that's what what um nhma was pointing
out to us so you're
right additional comments the chair
recognizes Vice and that is an RSA 60
let me see here 672 col 7 and I'll just
read it if I could land use boards means
a planning board historic district
commission inspector of building
building cord board of appeals soning
Board of adjustment or other boards or
commissions authorized by under RSA
673 established by the local legislative
body further question I mean further
comments representative frock Madam
chair is a motion to table appropriate
at this time no I don't know I'm you're
you're not Madam chair no one just
[Laughter]
impressed representative FR no it is not
thank
you are there any further
comments okay seeing none so the the
matter before the committee at this
point is a motion to
accept amendment number 225-6200
if you are in favor of the amendment you
will vote Yes if you are opposed to
accepting the amendment you will vote
no the clerk will call the
role Vice chair McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
no representative Dolan
no representative Alward no
clerk says
yes representative
France Representative karasinski
no representative Murphy
no representative Walker
no Representative stavis no
representative Gilman
yes Representative magor
no representative frock
yes representative Colby
no Representative gerana
no representative Gerard
no Representative grund no
chairman power
yes it's 5 to
13 the vote to accept Amendment 20
25- 62h to House Bill 92 fails with the
vote of 5
to13 the amendment is is not
accepted is there a motion
representative
McDonald
itl the motion before us
on House Bill 92 is itl is there a
second second representative Walker
seconds that motion discussion
representative majori thank you madam
chairwoman and and it may be it's a
question more towards process if if if
the if our committee believes there's a
chance to fix this with with another
amendment is it possible I know we have
to take a vote we have a motion to
dispose of is it possible to recess the
the the vote on this bill to try to work
on something if that be the the opinion
of the majority of the board uh of our
of our
committee representative majori I I do
believe that that that is
correct
um could I like to speak to
representative stavis
yesn't right
recess do see what she wants to
do e
okay so I just um conferred with the the
ranking member on the um proposal by the
deputy ranking member with regards to
this bill so we have a motion before us
which we need to dispose of we need to
take a vote on
that so what I can do is if the itl
motion
fails I can recess the executive
session
and the
members can work on an amendment and we
can exact this bill at a
later
time so does everybody
understand
yes represented McDonald
may I withdraw my itl
motion yes yes you
can um he you would need a second is
there a second on withdrawing the itl
motion second representative Murphy
seconds the withdrawal of the
itl it's
yeah and then you have then you
okay so this is executive session um
501 for a new chair
but um so yes the the emotion has been
um withdrawn so at this point in
time I will close the executive s
session on House Bill
92 yes representative Walker you closed
it shouldn't it been recessed so they
can work on
it isn't that what I said you said
closed
um
okay I meant recess there you go so I'm
I'm
withdrawing what I just said does is
there a second to that withdrawal of
that okay thank you
so the
chair recesses the executive session on
House Bill
92 e
at this time I will open the executive
session on um House Bill
99 and I would also like to offer an
amendment to House Bill 99 let me back
up I'm opening the exec I have I open
the executive session on House Bill 99
relative to waiver from property taxes
for disabled
veterans at this point I would like to
offer an amendment to House Bill 99 and
the amendment number is 2025
H second do I yeah do I have a second
representative gerana second thank you
second that
so I'd like to speak to to my Amendment
so the the bill as written would allow
municipalities to
increase the
optional disabled veterans tax credit to
cover um up to this is enabling
legislation 100% of the property
tax this bill came before this committee
last year with the same exact
language 100% is it's unworkable that is
not obviously a fixed number and there
are concerns with with that
specification of a percentage
because the property tax exemption if
that were to become law and this
optional tax credit were to be adopted
by a
town that tax credit would be different
for different veterans who qualified for
the tax credit because
each Veteran's
property
is valuated differently so that's a
concern um
additionally we
have let me just let me speak to the
amendment so what my
Amendment
does is
that it changes the the the maximum
allowable amount from $4,000 to
$5,000 and to me that's that's a
reasonable
Amendment change to this particular
statute because the last time that that
dollar amount was
changed was um let me
see I think it was in
20 it was some time ago so I think it
was in 2018 18 there there was a bill to
um increase
it yes so my notes Here say that it was
changed to the $4,000 amount in May of
2018 there was a bill and it became
effective January 2019 so the point
being is that um I thought that it would
be reasonable to adjust that upper
maximum allowable credit from the 4,000
to the 5000 ,000 to uh take into account
in
inflation Additionally you see that I
added the words permanent and on line
four as well as line six and the reason
that I thought that that was important
because when you take this
um optional tax
credit specified in statute under Roman
numeral 1A in you put it into the
context of
72 colon
35 it uses the language permanent and
total
disability and somehow that that
language got dropped and it probably
got I'm I'm assuming that it probably
got dropped um when there was a
bill when there was a bill to change 1A
and I think think that it's important
for clarity and understanding for um
towns when they
um go to adopt or they're um offering
this tax credit that that that it's
consistent so that that's the rationale
for adding that language in and then
lastly the I have additional language on
line
seven that and it specifies three
different four different um other tax
credits and the reason that I I did that
is to
prevent the stacking of of various tax
credits so
that we don't want to run into a
situation where perhaps uh uh an indiv
idual in the town who may apply may be
eligible and has applied for such tax
credits to um the mun the town to
actually owe the money so that's the
reason for that and you will see this
type of language in
other tax credits
sections is there any discussion on this
amendment representative Dolan right now
we we're um we're considering the
amendment to House Bill
99 well hold whether or not we we want
to accept it that's what's before us
right now so we need to dispose of
that representative
thank you
chairman um should you put in the line
with the effective date as
well on the
amendment let me
see thank you yeah thank you for
pointing that out and the answer would
be no because it's an amendment and it
says amend the bill by by replacing
section one and if you refer back to the
original
bill um we're only going to replace
section one which is lines one through
five on the original Bill and section
two
which discusses the effective date is is
still there but thank you
yeah that's
do I think
you okay I don't know what the procedure
is let me ask John
he said no yeah
okay just had to sort out a few details
here um any other
comments okay seeing none we're
um the matter before us at this point is
to accept the the amendment
20254 to House Bill 99 if you are in
favor favor of the amendment you will
vote Yes if you are opposed to accepting
the amendment you will vote no the clerk
will call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk says
yes representative
France representative kazinski
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Walker yes representative
stavis
yes representative Gilman
yes representative magor yes
representative FR
yes representative Colby
yes representative gerana
yes representative Gerard yes
representative grund
yes chairman chairman power
yes it's
180 the vote is 18 to Zer in favor of
accepting the amendment the amendment is
accepted do I have a
motion make a
motion as a so the motion before us is
ought to pass as Amendment as amended
and I we have representative kazinski
which seconds
that
discussion representative majority thank
you madam chairwoman just real quickly I
happen to uh be introducing a bill with
the prime sponsor of this I told him
that this might BEC coming he was
thrilled with with uh not only the not
only the increase to our veterans but
the way in which you calculated the
increase so just passing that along
thank
you further
discussions seeing none the clerk will
call wait
wait the motion before us is ought to
pass as amended on House Bill 99
the the clerk will all right if you're
in favor of the motion you'll vote Yes
if you're opposed you'll vote no the
clerk will call the
role chairman McDonald excuse me Vice
chairman
McDonald
yes representative
Guthrie representative Dolan yes
representative Elward
yes the clerk says
yes representative
France representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker yes representative stavis yes
representative Gilman
yes representative magor yes
representative frock yes representative
Colby yes representative Jama yes
representative Gerard
yes representative grund
yes chairman
power yes
180 the vote on the motion ought to pass
as amended on House Bill 99 is 18 to
zero the motion passes the committee
recommendation is ought to pass as
amended without objection the
recommendation will go on to the consent
calendar seeing none
and I will write the committee report
with that I will close the executive
session on House Bill
99 next I will open the executive
session on House Bill 101 relative to
exempting certain elderly homeowners
from paying property
taxes do I have a motion the chair
recognizes representative stavis for a
motion thank you madam mam chair I move
itl on this bill is there a
second a second representative mcdonal
seconds that motion would you like to
speak to your motion representative
Davis yes I would thank you again Madam
chair um I
I thank the representative who brought
us this bill I think that his intentions
are good um but there are many many
problems with the bill we have seen
bills like this come before our
committee in years past and kind of the
gold standard for judging tax exemption
bills is a means
testing um standard there is none in
this bill all you have to do is reach
the um very very very Advanced age of 72
and you no longer have to pay any
property taxes whatsoever even if you
are the CEO of a major multinational
company and you live in a $2 million
mansion and make $3 billion a year and
there is no mechanism in the bill to um
say to the state
um that you could very well afford to
pay your property taxes and so on that
technical basis and philosophical basis
both of those alike I I would recommend
that we itl this Bill thank you madam
chair further comments representative
Guthrie
just quickly uh Madam chair because I'm
in this
category uh way in this category but
there I just to comment that there is a
real
feeling uh in in some communities that
we should do something for the uh
elderly but it certainly has to be uh
some uh parameters as far as the amount
of money some of us are well off and
some of us many of us are left with a
sing being a single person with only
Social Security and I think we really
have to help them and most towns are
already doing that we increased in my
town we increased the parameters and we
are doing it uh assisting people who are
70 years old uh and U um are really
doing everything we can to help our our
seniors with low income so I think is
there but this is a poorly written B
Bill further
comments seeing none the motion before
us on House Bill 101 relative to
exempting certain elderly homeowners
from paying property
taxes is inexpedient to legislate if you
are in favor of the itl motion you will
vote Yes if you are opposed to the itl
motion you will vote
no the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk says
yes representative France
yes representative karinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker yes representative stavis yes
representative Gilman
yes representative magor yes
representative frock
yes representative Colby yes
representative jamana yes representative
Gerard yes representative grundt yes
chairman power
yes 18 to Z the vote is 18 to0 the
motion passes the committee
recommendation on House
Bill number was it 99 oh 101 101 Sor is
inexpedient to legislate without
objection the recommendation will go
onto the consent
calendar seeing
none and representative state
you will Author the committee report
thank
you with that I will close the executive
session on House Bill
101 at this time I will open the
executive session on House Bill
110 authorizing counties to establish
revolving fund
accounts
so in front of you you see a um a
handout that's stapled and it's quite
long from left to
right there
I myself and representative
stavis and potentially
others worked
on language for an amendment to this
bill so just very briefly I'm going to
explain what this long handout is so the
committee researcher was um kind
enough to provide at my request a a side
by side by side comparison on the Fly um
with regards to the the the two
different amendments and the bill as
introduced so at this point in time I
would like to
offer Amendment
2025 57h to House Bill 110 is there a
second second represent Murphy seconds
that thank
you
okay
so again just very briefly the the
amendment that we're considering here
right now is 0057 H and as you recall
from the hearing on the bill that there
was an
amendment
subsequently the Prime sponsor got
together with stakeholders and worked on
an additional Amendment and so right off
the bat what I noticed is that the
amendment that we're
considering looks a lot like the
original bill as
written
so I'd like to point out the the changes
that that I um pointed out and that that
are in this particular Amendment and the
changes were to
address uh language in the the the bill
the amendment that that that needed some
adjustment so the first thing that that
you can will note is throughout the bill
on line
six um line seven I mean line
20 you will notice the the the
word County delegation for legislative
body so that's it's the county
delegation they are the legislative body
but it's it's better language to to
specify the words County
delegation so that's that's that the
other thing that I thought that was
important with regards to feedback that
we heard during the hearing was the
whole notion of just a revolving fund so
I
suggested that the the section be more
narrowly titled and defined within the
language of this new section to
specifically specify a County public
safety revolving fund I thought that
that went a long way to to help um with
regards to this new
section so additionally there
was some concerns with if you would see
the side by-side comparison doesn't have
line numbers but nevertheless in section
two if you look at col the leftmost
column to the middle column which is 57h
the amendment we're looking at notice
the highlighted Words May became
shall that was important because shall
means you're going to do it it's not an
option so it says that if now to be
clear this is a this is an an
enabling statute if it becomes law so
it's optional it's um counties don't
have to do this but if a county
establishes a County public safety
revolving fund for the purposes
identified in paragraph Roman numeral
one it shall deposit into the
fund and as I said it's it's not an OP
it's not an option May deposit into the
fund so I thought that was important and
then if you um go down in the middle
column you you see further clarifying
language that's highlighted and the
Clause is put in or propositional phrase
to replenish the fund to the original
appropri created
amount so
that puts like a cap on the revolving
fund so the original amount that was
voted for the for the fund that's that's
how much money can can be in the the
fund and then further language says the
county shall deposit any other revenues
approved by the county delegation into
the revolving fund provided that funds
in excess of the original appropriated
amount shall be deposited into the
general fund so what that's saying is
that
if so you have money coming into to the
purpose to this specific County public
safety revolving
fund and what it's saying is that the
funds shall be deposited into this
revolving fund and excess shall be
deposited into the general fund and
that's putting I guess guard rails if
you will so that the excess money goes
into the general fund and it's not put
into some other line item hope that
makes
sense and then you will also notice that
there's the requirement that the County
Treasurer will have custody of all
monies in the fund and shall pay out the
same only upon order of the County
Commissioners so a a concern that was
voiced during the hearing is that with
the amendment that the prime sponsor
presented and spoke to there was no
agent um specified and that's why you
see
that and that covers it that covers the
comparison of the amendment that we have
before us to the the the original bill
as written so is there any discussion
comments representative
frock thank you madam chair
um the language I I've lost it for the
moment okay uh Roman numeral 4 the
provisions of the section shall not
preclude the establishment of a County
public safety revolving fund for any
other
purpose um I'm not sure that I
understand the meaning of that uh
because the bill or the amendment
establishes the County public safety
fund and where would another one for a
different purpose come
in um
so the the
language that section section four if
you look at the bill as written and as
referred to the committee that whole
room and numeral section of four is is
in in the
bill and the only thing that's different
with regards to the amendment that's
before us is the um
modifying words of County public
safety modifying revolving
fund so that's the best answer I can
give to that speaking to the amendment
at this time representative Gilman thank
you madam chair um I'm a little confused
by some of the language um uh line 14
through
17 um I understand that the county can
deposit the revenues approved for that
the purpose of that revolving
fund but then the providing funds in
excess for that purpose then go to the
general fund that that's one question
how can you do that if you're if you're
putting money in for a specific purpose
and then next the following line the
money in the fund shall all be allowed
to accumulate from year to year so if
there's extra funds why are they being
allowed to accumulate or be returned to
the general fund okay so um with regards
to your first comment
um as was explained to me by by the
prime prime sponsor that
the the payment for services rendered
for the purpose of providing Public
Safety
those
payments are to go into this revolving
fund and
that any extra that's above and and
Beyond what was specified by the county
delegation when the fund
was adopted or
accepted W would go to the general fund
so the point being is that there's
there's two places
first the the the monies for services
rendered shall go into this revolving
fund and extra will go
into the general fund to answer the
second part of your your
comment with regards
to money accumulating yes money can
accum accumulate in the revolving
fund it's not considered excess
until the money that has accumulated
exceeds the amount that was established
by the county are specified by the
county delegation at the time that the
revolving fund was
established I I'm still not clear on how
you can do this with a revolving fund uh
it it's like saying you're saying the
opposite thing that any excess funds
goes to the general fund which is um not
the purpose of a revolving fund
especially if it's allowed to accumulate
from year to year which is the opposite
of putting the extra funds into the
general
fund and we're talking I think we're
using the same words but not necessarily
in the same order
so may I offer that both
representative stavis and I spent a
considerable considerable amount of time
yesterday speaking with the with the
prime sponsor to to to to to work on
this language and to to get it right
Additionally the prime sponsor met with
stakeholders and they provided
input so that's that's my best
understanding of it I am not a um
Financial
expert and I did Grill the prime sponsor
to seek understanding so that I could
explain it here to the committee which
um I believe and I checked my
understanding with him and and so that's
the that's the best that I can do to
explain and I I do have confidence in in
in um the way this is set up perhaps
the chair can Rec will recognize
representative stavis for um further
clarification thank you madam chair
thank you madam chair um I'd like to
make a
motion I'd like to move itl on this bill
and I'd like to speak to my
motion okay so I I believe that we need
to dispose of this amendment
right no
so we do have an emotion
an a motion to accept this this
amendment that's what's before us so we
have to dispose of
that is there any other further
discussion on the amendment
representative
Gerard thank you madam chair um looking
through the amendment some of my
concerns is kind of the same things
other people spoke of talks about
depositing any other revenues which
again I'm not sure what any other
revenues would be if you're billing out
for for example construction traffic
that should be the only Revenue so I'm
not sure what else because I think that
would have a effect on the county budget
by the time we're done because we then
wouldn't be putting the revenues back to
where they long it almost feels like
we're trying to fix a problem that if
the delegation and the County
Commissioners are setting their budget
properly that they are able to have a
enough expenses and enough Revenue in
there so it actually doesn't have any
effect on the tax purposes but I also
had the same concern is representative
Gilman about the line that says the
money and the fund shall be allowed to
accumulate I would understand if it said
roll over but accumulate and again
because it would be going from one year
to the next year Rolling the the balance
over cuz the first year you're going to
have to put uh seed money into this to
which is going to affect the the tax
rate as well so uh that's just some of
my
concerns my I would just like to briefly
respond to that so yes that is correct
that seed money will need to come from a
line item but um to be clear my
understanding with regards to a
revolving fund as a as a budgetary tool
is is is reasonable and the the the
reason this bill was was brought forward
is because the way that things are being
done today right now is it's
um it's not it's it's tying
hands um maybe that's not the the right
word but it the a revolving fund is is a
tool a
to to be able to provide these types of
services to be able to accept payment
for services rendered and then to be
able to pay the um law and the county
law enforcement agents to be able to
provide those
services
so the last thing that I'll say is that
the way that
it's things are set up now and the way
that things work now is that with a
particular line item that you have to
kind you have to guess and so there's
the concern that the county might over
budget and therefore over tax that the
County residents so I I to me this is
this is a this is a reasonable and
proper financial tool a revolving fund
but all right so I saw someone else that
had a comment representative
kazinski yes um in town we use this and
the idea behind it is that you can't
budget for something that's coming up
that you don't know and these Public
Safety details are going to happen and
you're going to have to fund it somehow
so if you
put monies in an account just the seed
money you're going to do that every year
anyway even without a revolving fund but
as the money comes back in you're paying
your personnel and expenses out of that
fund hopefully you are charging more
than the cost so the excess money should
go back to the general fund and the
taxpayer and then I think that seed
money will eventually come out but at
least the next year it won't have to go
in to the point that you're starting the
next budget cycle with the revolving
fund having enough money to initially
start paying
the Personnel if I got that right so
thank you thank you further comments the
chair recognizes representative
Davis thank you madam chair I I have no
issue with the basic um intent and
intent and purpose here we go um of of
this bill I think
that when all is said and done it's
probably a very good
idea as my colleague just said uh my
problem and it's kind of been a problem
all along is we I don't feel that we on
this committee have the accounting
expertise to write this the right
way um and and my concern is that we're
going to miss a word here or miss a word
there and in that one or two
words a a world of Mischief could be
done so I I don't trust myself to be
sure um I can't speak for others but I
certainly don't trust myself to write
this in a way that it's kind of Ironclad
that nothing could go wrong here
and I I would like to be sure in my own
mind that that we have constructed
something that is
foolproof and that accounting experts
agree you know yes this is the accepted
practice this this is what's going to
work these are the things that it will
prevent from going wrong and if I if I
was confident in that I'd be more
confident in it overall but I do not
disagree with the premise of the
bill further question I meant
comments representative grund thank you
and thank you uh representative Davis
for the comments around that I think
there is a a lot of detail that could
would be very minute but one of the
things that doesn't necessarily address
for me is also it does say the uh payout
the same upon order of the County
Commissioners I just want to make sure
that there's an approval process that
the county commissioner has to go
through in order to move the money
around is there whether it's approval by
the delegation or the board um that the
executive board that works with them um
just to make sure that there's an
authorization to move money around
so the the answer to that would would
would be yes so just to reiterate the
the the legislative body which is the
county
delegation would vote to to to authorize
to provide this this revolving fund and
so the specification of the the
Commissioners is the checks and balances
so the the Commissioners would would
have to
approve um those that that those
actions
yes representative majori thank you
madam chairwoman I'm just curious if uh
it's a two-park question just curious if
one of the stakeholders that was
consulted was the association of
counties and if they took a
position it is my understanding that
is this the new
hampsh New Hampshire when Kate Horan's
here it's my understanding that that
they that that they were at the table um
with a number of other stakeholders okay
thank
you further
comments seeing
none the the the matter before us is to
accept the amendment number
2025 57h to House Bill
110 the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Elward yes the clerk says
yes representative fr
Bron representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker yes Representative stavis
no represent representative Gilman
no Representative
magor
no representative frock no
representative Colby no representative
gerana
yes representative Gerard
no representative grund
L chairman power
yes 11 to S
wait yes 11 to seven
the vote to accept the amendment
2025-the
M McDonald I move AR to passes amended
is there a sec is there a
second second representative Dolan
seconds that motion ought to pass as
amended
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call our the clerk will call the
role and let me just state that um the
motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
110 Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan yes
representative Elward
yes clerk says
yes representative
France representative karinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman
no Representative
magor
no representative frock
no representative Colby
no representative gerana
yes representative Gerard
no Representative grundt
no chairman power
yes 11 the motion passes with a vote of
11 to7 the committee recommendation on
House Bill
110 is ought to pass as amended
representative McDonald will write the
majority report and Minority
Report would you like to somebody author
a Minority
Report rep representative grunt thank
you who is it grunt
so with that I will close the executive
session on House Bill
110 so last I would like to open the
executive session on House Bill 78
requiring a person to have a domicile in
the district from which they serve as
County
Commissioner okay at this time uh I
would like to offer an amendment for
accept acceptance by the committee and
that is amendment
2025 d34
so um the reason we have this amendment
in in front of us is as you recall um
the good Senator um from
Rochester he came to the committee and
had an amendment and the house cannot
um amend a senate Amendment so
therefore the we had to
have OSS draft a house Amendment so
that's what's before us so what the
purpose of the amendment is is that it
um it further
clarifies
language requ establishing residency
requirements so as you can see in lines
the bold print in the amendment six and
seven
there there was some you concerns that
we heard at at the hearing um so
nevertheless so you can read it it says
that it requires that the the
person shall be at the time of his or
her election an inhabitant who resides
actually and permanently in the county
from which he or she is chosen and that
same language uh
appears on lines 10 through 13 and also
further specifies
that um upon the time in which the
person uh ceases to be
qualified that they will no longer um
represent the district that they were
elected to
represent so um this language here was
inspired by the New Hampshire
Constitution
that's where I came up with the word
inhabitant and additionally I further
strengthened that
requirement with the legal definition of
inhabitant which um specifies or defines
it as a person who resides actually and
permanently in a
place do I have a second did I ask for a
second already I'm sorry I I was just
okay thank you um that's representative
Walker I apologize I should ask for a
second
um comments discussion on this
amendment representative
Colby oh just curious um let's see line
four five well I guess five six
seven um it says shall be at the time of
his or her election does this give the
person an opportunity to to
register and then move to a
County register to vote
uh to uh declare
candidacy um with the intention of
moving to said
County upon winning his or her
election or is that already going to be
covered um sufficiently in Secretary of
State paperwork
land
I well the the the intent of the
language is that the per it's
establishing
domicile so I guess your question has to
do with
I suppose it it just talking it out I
think it could be covered likely
somewhere in Secretary of State um you
know running for
office well
I I believe that's most
likely the
answer um representative Murphy thank
you madam chair my the question the
problem I have is when you file and
for a county or other position State Rep
or what have you you have to do that I
believe in
June or thereabouts so that person would
have to already established residency at
that point not at the time of the
election in
November
that's so my my my response to that
would be in order for the person to file
that that is true so in order to file
they have to establish
residency well they can't if they if
they if they are ineligible to file then
it's a moot point we don't even get to
this yeah I I it could be I don't know I
just I'm concerned that this might cause
confusion shall be at the time of his or
her election and inhabitant who
resides yeah just to clarify
in order for a person to be eligible to
file they have to have
established a domicile so the the filing
is is is
already has passed it's already a
thing representative majority thank you
madam chairwoman um but isn't that the
ambiguity that we are trying to fix
because in straford County right now
you have people filing and running in
different
districts so that's the problem they are
they they still would be able to file in
a different
district am I am I am I missing
that maybe I'm looking to Mr Walker or
representative Walker excuse me who may
may seem to help
me representative Walker do you have a
comment
it could be a little bit confusing
because it says the election not the
filing for
office someone might take that as a
loophole that I live in Ward
five I'll file for the ward four slot
and then by the election I have to move
there so you got the same problem you
got
now representative Gilman thank you
madam chair
uh I think I thought at the time the
original original bill that we were
trying to solve a problem that happened
with the redistricting of the or the
districting I should say of stord
County sorry
um but this uh so districting stord
County which had not had been electing
Commissioners at large so when the when
we pass the bill to district straford
county
someone was running in a district in an
area at large that now had a had a
district commissioner so they were not
living in the district that they came
from because there hadn't been district
lines so this amendment
doesn't is I I
agree I agree with it been said before
that um it has to be at the time that
they uh register for candidates
see because of that um changing of
lines thank you okay so um what I will
direct members to do right now is to
um recognize that we have this amendment
before us we also had the the Senate
Amendment which essentially is doing the
same
thing and furthermore um the amend ments
aside we have we we can look at the
original language of the bill okay
so if you look at the original language
of the bill
as the
statute as written that I mean nothing's
really changing because if you go back
and you look at the the original bill
the only bold that we see is on line six
and straford correct so just to be clear
this whole discussion about a person
must have a doile in the county for
which he is chosen that's current
statute
correct
so the reason why we that that I'm
offering this amendment because I was
going off of the amendment that was
brought here
here um by the
senator is this making
sense representative
Elward maybe to add to the confusion but
just because you file for candidacy
doesn't mean you're going to win so why
would you move
yourself in anticipation
of a
win if you don't
win further
comments representative kazinski what I
found on the internet is to be a county
commissioner in New Hampshire you have
to be a citizen of the United States be
at least 21 years old be eligible to
vote and have been a resident of the
district for at least 30
days okay
I think you're right as far as the
Secretary of State's office and what
they have for eligibility
requirements further
comments representative Davis thank you
madam chair is there any reason why we
can't take the Senate
Amendment and just make it a house
Amendment and move that
we we we cannot do that because it's a
senate Amendment that's how it came out
of OSS we we can't do
that no unfortunately so just to be
clear
anyway the amendment that's before you
does the in my mind the same thing as
the Senate
Amendment with improved terms like L
like
I liked inhabitant
better so
um versus
domicile further questions um no
questions comments discussion
representative
Murphy what's wrong with plagiarism
nothing but I to be honest I I I like to
um put my own touch on
things representative
stavis thank you madam chair I don't
like plagiarism just for the record um
can I copy you on
that um how would you feel how would you
all feel about just getting rid of the
words at the time of his or her
election what what line is this that I'm
sorry it is in the amendment it's lines
uh line six six
so to to be clear um if we go back and
we look at the bill as filed that that
language is is there at the time of his
election and that's what is currently in
statute so if we go back and we look at
the bill as filed the only changes was
the and was struck to add in the county
of
straford so we're we're we're kind of
splitting hairs or laser focusing on
something
that's already in statute and that's not
what we're that's not really what the
amendment is
about because um let me
see that'll be home the bill where's the
amend can I see the amendment
Madam yes oh representative frock thank
you madam chair if the original bill as
introduced is and is current law and the
only change is eliminate
the and before Carol and adding and
straford why is there a need for an
amendment that just seems to be muddying
the
waters thank you representative F frock
that is a point well taken so the
options are if people do not like the
amendment that's before
us we can
not accept that and we can revert to the
bill as filed and if this bill makes it
over to the other
chamber the good Senator over there can
do what he wants to
it does that make sense
abely so right now we're we're
considering the amendment 2025
h-34 so is there any further discussion
or comments on this seeing none so what
we're going to do is we're going to um
dispose of this matter before us so the
motion before us is accepting Amendment
2025-the
to House Bill 78 so if you're in favor
of the amendment you will vote Yes if
you are opposed to accepting the
amendment you will vote no and then
after we sort that out then we can no
amendments we go back to the bill as
filed and then we can take a motion on
that
okay so the clerk will call the role
Vice chairman
McDonald
yes representative
Guthrie representative Dolan yes
representative Elward
yes clerk says
yes representative France
yes representative kazinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker yes Representative stavis no
representative Gilman no Representative
magor no representative frock no
representative Colby no representative
gerna
yes representative Gerard
yes Representative grund
no chairman
power yes
so the the motion to accept the
amendment passes
12-6 do I have a further motion on the
bill as
amended
representative bronze do you have a
motion
I make a motion
to uh
Opa on HB
78 is there a second second okay so the
motion before us is ought to pass as
amended with
Amendment
2025 d00
34h on House Bill 78 discussion
seeing
none we're going to vote on the motion
ought to pass as amended on House Bill
78 if you're in favor of the motion
you'll vote Yes if you're opposed you
will vote no the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative Dolan yes yes
representative award yes clerk says
yes representative France yes
representative Kosinski yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Walker yes Representative stavis no
representative Gilman no Representative
magor no representative frock
no representative Colby no no
representative jamana
yes representative Gerard
yes representative grund
yes chairman power
yes the motion ought to pass as amended
on on House Bill 78 passes with a vote
of
13-5 the committee recom recommendation
on House Bill 78 is ought to pass as
amended the committee report will be
authored the majority report will be
authored by representative bronze and
would the minority like to author a
report okay representative
majority okay
with that I will close the executive
session on House Bill
78 so um that concludes our publicly
noticed business for today but before we
we adjourn I have a few afternoon
announcements to find
them okay afternoon
announcements so for the week of January
we have scheduled a more hearings and an
executive session on Thursday January
30th for the week the following week
which is the week of February 2nd I plan
uh we we should plan to meet on Monday
February
3rd additionally there's a house session
tentatively planned for Thursday
February
6th so uh also to date last time I
checked there are a total of 58 house
bills that have been referred to this
committee to reiterate I would like to
not have to meet during the last week in
February to give people a
break so in order to do this as the
weeks go on we might need to pick up um
an additional day between now and then
but stay tuned on that and additionally
I'd like to
just remind members that if you want to
offer an amendment to a bill please
inform both myself the chair as well as
the ranking
member so the reason is a couple of
things um we want to understand who is
working on amendments so that we can um
make sure that it's the process is
moving along additionally I would like
to avoid the chance that multiple people
are working on the same type of an
amendment um to the same bill we don't
want to waste members time or the um
resources at OS so if we could
coordinate that um that that would be
great and also um the chair and ranking
member is here to assist you with a
language two heads are better than one
um also with regards to amendments
please submit any requests to OSS sooner
than later
because I would like for any amendments
to be shared with this committee all
committee members at least 48 hours
ahead of a scheduled executive session
so that we can read the
amendment understand the
amendment and um sort things out so that
things aren't
um as complex when we go to exec a bill
also please be aware that if you are
requesting an amendment through the
portal the intake sheet asks you to
specify a date and a time that the
amendment is needed the chair
made the innocent mistake of putting
into those fields the date and time of
the executive session so I um uh
realized my my um misunderstanding and
clarified it with OS and so I thought OS
was going to back up and and say oh well
we're gonna we're gonna release this so
that the committee has enough time to to
read it
they're not going to do that calculation
so I'm just recommending that um make
your request accordingly so that we can
get amendments to committee members at
least 48
hours I mean if it's
24 okay but that's not that's not the
preference and also once you get an
amendment don't hold on to it to to
check with somebody else or have a
discussion
if you need to redraft an amendment and
we're within that 48h hour window you
don't have to offer the amendment but we
want to be able to have the members to
be able to receive the amendment in a
timely fashion and to be able to read it
and
also whether you call into ol or go in
in person um please be sure to request
especially that in the in the portal
that you want copies from
HCS and then go upstairs in the morning
get those copies and distribute them to
um committee members so lastly members
writing committee reports please have
those to the chair within 48 hours which
is going to be sometime on Saturday if
something happens and you're like
catastrophic and you can't do that don't
worry please contact me and will work
something out but I do need everybody to
understand that these I I need to look
at the the the committee reports make
sure that they're you know in accordance
with the the the format and the
guideline and then I also need to pass
that to the committee researcher and
then those reports go to the speaker so
there's
people after me that that need to be
able to Review Committee reports and
then those reports need to be um put
into the house calendar by a deadline on
Wednesday so that's that's that's why
okay so finally as always please do not
hesitate to reach out to myself the
chair or the ranking member
representative stavis with any questions
because we are here to assist you help
you and work with you so um I app
appreciate your patience this has been a
long day it's been um a very busy week
with all the Amendments I thank people
that um raise their hand to submit
amendments I that's I I really do
appreciate that and um thank you for
your patience and um hopefully next time
we meet the your
chair's um scheduling algorithm will be
improved so yes representative stavis I
just I just wanted to ask if all of the
new committee members are familiar with
the HCS
process not really may I yes so HCS is
house committee Services it's located on
the fourth floor of this
building and if you go to your
legislative email account and you just
type in
HCS in the address line it'll populate
for you and you can send them um
enclosures of documents like amendments
that you want to have printed in advance
of a meeting with a requests saying how
many you want to have printed you know
please have them ready by XYZ time and
then before the meeting you can just zip
up to the fourth floor and pick them up
and it's a wonderful
service representative frock oop sorry I
didn't see
um Madam chair uh I would respectfully
point out that if it is your practice to
schedule the exact
sessions in the next committee meeting
following the public
hearing
[Music]
um the amount of time to produce
amendments is impossible to meet your
schedule
specifically uh January 30th which is a
week from
today and there is one business day
between January 30th and our next
meeting on February 3D
okay thank you representative frock any
meetings of this committee for February
3rd which is a Monday has not yet been
scheduled but I will take your comments
under advisement I appreciate that thank
you
representative majori thank you m chair
I just want to extend my uh my my thanks
to you and especially the clerk or or
appreciation for uh doing this as
newbies and having sat next to the clerk
for for an entire session I I know I've
seen how much work you have to do so
thank you for navigating especially
since we have taken you off the rails
not intentionally it was not we didn't
come up with partis and issues but
that's just the way it happens when you
have 18 people sitting in the room who
who all have an opinion opion so uh well
done on navigating through the Quagmire
which we have
created thank you representative um I I
think that the conductor of this train
has been able to keep this train on the
tracks and thank you for um all the cars
lining
up so with that um the municipal and
County government committee is adjourned
for today thank you and have a great